Musik
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So.
Moin.
Lass mal checken, ob du es hier findest.
So.
Warte mal.
Irgendwie bin ich gerade auf dem Kabel drauf
Am Schuh
Excellent
So, ich bin nicht mehr afk
Klo
Ja, ich hatte heute eigentlich ein bisschen vor
Nachher noch, also nach dem Stream
Einmal in Frankfurt den Livestream zu gucken
Aber das wird heute nichts
Weil die haben ja nur verkürzte Strecke
Was heißt
Die sind wahrscheinlich in drei Stunden
Und dann sind wir fertig
Dann bin ich noch am Stream
Ich wollte eigentlich heute Mittag noch ein bisschen gucken
so die letzten, keine Ahnung, 15, 20 Kilometer.
Aber
das wird jetzt nichts.
Da haben sich ja viele extrem aufgeregt.
Wartet mal, irgendwie ist, irgendwas stimmt hier nicht.
Wartet mal kurz.
Oder ist es mein Ohr?
Moment.
Ist es mein Ohr?
Oder ist das
mein Headset?
Die Kunde braucht ein bisschen entspanntere Musik.
Das könnte auch mein Ohr sein.
Weil ich höre auf der linken Seite mehr als auf der rechten Seite.
WTF?
Naja gut, vielleicht ist es auch mein Ohr.
Man weiß ja nicht.
Aber euch ist alles okay, oder?
Ich komme auf der linken Seite genauso laut raus, wie auf der rechten Seite, oder?
Ich entknote mal mein Headset, Leute.
Ich entknote mal mein Headset.
Ist irgendwas, irgendwas...
Ich glaube, das liegt an meinem Ohr.
Jetzt aber, oder?
Ja. Ist jetzt besser?
Ich weiß nicht.
Könnte sein. Könnte sein, dass es besser ist.
Egal. Das ist ja manchmal,
wenn man nachts irgendwie nur auf einer Seite gelegen hat,
dass man dann morgens vielleicht ein bisschen auf der Seite schlecht erhört.
Das dauert dann irgendwie erstmal
ein paar Minuten, bis es wieder...
So.
Eigentlich warte ich jetzt nur noch drauf,
dass mein Logitech-Zeug checkt,
dass die Tastatur
dran ist.
Ah,
jetzt hat es gecheckt.
Bei Hits ist es als Selbst-
Ich weiß nicht. Also, da kann man sich jetzt
drüber streiten. Also, ich gehe davon aus,
also, die haben ja den Ironman in Frankfurt,
den haben die verkürzt.
3,8 Kilometer schwimmen,
bleibt gleich. Fahrradstrecke
wurde verkürzt, glaube ich, von 180 auf
120 Kilometer und statt 40
Kilometer wird jetzt 20 Kilometer gerannt.
Also da waren sehr viele
Leute gar nicht gut drauf zu sprechen,
weil
die gesagt haben, die haben sich
ein Ticket gekauft, aber zahlst ja teilweise
700 Euro Startgebühr
beim Ironman Frankfurt. Die haben gesagt,
sie haben sich angemeldet für einen vollen Ironman
und die wollen jetzt gefälligst auch einen vollen Ironman machen
bei
700 Euro Startgebühr. Das kann ich schon
nachvollziehen, ja.
Außerdem, also gerade bei den Profis würde ich mir da gar keine Gedanken machen.
Ich meine, da ist ja auch in, wobei letzten Sinitsa oder irgendwo haben sie glaube ich abgesagt sogar.
Naja, zumindest dort wo die anderen Ironmans sind in anderen Ländern ist ja auch warm.
Also keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, ob das so gut ist, dass sie das verkürzt haben.
Auf der anderen Seite... Hallo? Kannst du mal angehen, Mini-PC? Hallo? Mini-PC, please angehen.
Äh, chat ich? Ah, okay, es braucht einfach nur eine ganze Weile.
So, darf ich jetzt endlich mein Passwort eingeben?
Hat eigentlich der Sellout funktioniert, Chat?
Kam am Anfang das Banner?
Wenn nicht, muss ich das nochmal resetten.
Ja, denke ich auch.
Die Leute machen das ja freiwillig.
Ich denke auch.
Ich finde es eigentlich nicht gut, dass es verkürzt wurde.
Ich meine, ich kann es schon zum Teil nachvollziehen.
Ich meine, man darf ja auch nicht vergessen, da sind ja auch viele Helfer und Verpflegungsleute und alles dabei, die an der Hitze rumstehen müssen.
Okay.
Aber trotzdem, also an sich finde ich es eigentlich nicht gut.
Aber abbrechen tut da wahrscheinlich eh keiner.
Bis zum Umfallen machen die das.
Was?
Wie?
Äh, fail to connect?
Stimmt überhaupt nicht
Funktioniert doch
Omega Ludel
Das sind alles High Performer
Naja, du brauchst schon ein gewisses
Durchhaltevermögen
Ja, dass du es von allem entpackst
So, also erstmal aufwachen.
Also ja, eher aufwachen streamen, das passt doch.
So.
Erstmal kurz gucken, ob ich den Sellout resetten muss.
Ah.
Okay.
Ab jetzt alle 25 Minuten müsste das eigentlich kommen.
Dann machen wir doch hier mal...
Chat, darf man eigentlich seine Artstealungs mittlerweile wieder updaten?
Ist das...
Ist das eigentlich alles wieder okay mittlerweile?
Ich habe meine Archilux nicht mehr geupdatet, seitdem diese ganze Geschichte war.
Warum sollte man das nicht?
Weil ganz viele Arch-User-Repo-Pakete manipuliert waren.
Natürlich unter der Haube wieder per NPM-Package.
Was sonst?
NPM-Package ist ja angesagt, was das angeht.
Wir gucken mal,
ob es...
Guck mal, es gibt noch nicht mal
Our Package Updates.
Das ist ja gut.
Pac-Man, das können wir machen.
Das ist okay.
Moment, sehe ich das richtig?
11 Gigabyte.
Krass.
Heftig.
11 GB.
Na da haben wir jetzt ein bisschen was zu updaten.
Und unsere Jetbrains Sachen müssen wahrscheinlich auch mal geupdatet werden.
Ne müssen nicht. Echt nicht. Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht da gibt es mehr.
Ist nur PyCharm.
Ist da ein Model dabei? Nö.
einfach nur ganz normale Packages sind das 11 Gig.
Also vielleicht hat mittlerweile irgendwie
ein lokales LLM
als Dependency,
das weiß man ja in der heutigen Zeit nicht.
Aber es sieht nach ganz normalen Packages aus.
Aber das Schöne ist,
bei Arch Linux,
Ach, DaVinci Resolve wird geupdatet.
Okay, ja, das erklärt es natürlich.
Das ist ja immer, das ist ja
huge AF.
Hugel ist das, hugel.
Moment, ich habe meine Pillen vergessen. Sekunde.
Warte mal, reinhauen.
Was hast du geträumt? Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Irgendein Schwachsinn bestimmt.
Oh, was ist das?
Aber der zweite Dauner hat bestimmt funktioniert, oder?
Snapshots werden gemacht.
Da müssen wir auf jeden Fall gleich rebooten, wenn da keine Updates dabei sind.
Der DaVinci Resolve wird geupgradet.
Ja, das macht wahrscheinlich 6 Gig von den 11 Gig aus.
x-bit
gibt es das überhaupt noch
oder ist das was anderes
früher waren die Videos die man sich
die Linux Distributionen die man sich
früher runtergeladen hat die waren immer
in x-bit x-bit oder div x
Format
das war so noch lange vor
h.264 und sowas
Du hast ein cooles Auto gesehen.
Moment, guck ich mir jetzt mal an.
Ah ne, vonzternet, ich bin auf dem zweiten PC nicht eingeloggt im Discord.
MonkaS, geh nicht.
Du müsstest das Bild posten, also das, kannst ja einen Discord-Link auf das PNG posten,
dann geht das.
Ich kann nicht gucken sonst.
So, guck mal, wie schnell das ging.
Unter Red Hat hätte ich jetzt erstmal eine halbe Stunde
da gesessen, 11 Gig Package Updates.
Und jetzt...
Reboot.
Wenn man das jetzt noch richtig schreiben könnte.
Guck mal, ist das nicht geil?
Ich kann so viele Rs machen, wie ich will
und Tab drücken und mir dann auswählen
zwischen wie viele Rs ich beim Reboot haben will.
Reboot.
Oh, jetzt muss ich die Tastatur wieder umstöpseln, dass ich mein Passwort eingeben kann.
Okay, ich guck gleich.
Auf mir den PC mach hinne.
Dann gucken wir mal, was auf GitHub so trendet.
Zack.
Hullscreen.
Plixer.
Massive Subscription.
Danke für den Sub.
Ja, nice.
Eieiei.
Na gut, die machen ja auch,
die machen ja auch Werbung dafür, ne?
Das ist ja das Weep-Auto
schlechthin, ne?
Weeps detected, Leute.
So, da sind wir ja.
Firefox.
Zack.
Ready.
Machen wir mal den ganzen Kram hier zu, den wir da noch
aufhaben. Wobei, ne, das lag... Moment,
Moment, Moment. Ich bin ja auch blöd. Warum mach ich denn das zu?
Das passt ja überhaupt nicht.
Ich muss mein...
Mein Sellout muss ich schon auflassen.
Den brauchen wir ja gleich wieder.
Ja
Selbst ein bisschen Wärmung stellst du hier
Meinst du, der Laut, den brauchen wir ja gleich
Okay
Hier, guck mal, die Katz hat mich wieder besucht
Wo wir gerade dabei sind
Die Katz hat mich wieder besucht
Und war super, super entspannt
Guck mal, die streckt sogar die Zunge raus
So entspannt ist die
Super entspannte Katz
Die lag bei mir so auf der Terrasse
Terrasse.
Im Schatten. Der ist auch zu warm.
45 Jahre.
Deluxe-Längschen für den Sub.
Pog-Subscription.
Danke für den Sub.
Und auch an den
Splixer gibt es jetzt einen.
Alfred, danke für den Sub.
Pog.
Github schon mal auf.
Github trending.
Das Scam-Train ist am Laufen.
Lasst euch ruhig scammen.
Die Abo-Falle schnappt zu.
es sieht immer so aus als hätte ich polyzitter anfälle hier das ist die
maus software die wackelt ab und zu so rum
6 uhr gelüftet jetzt wieder ein 30,5 grad in der wohnung chatarino start noch
ja
Bei mir ist es auch warm, aber ich habe glücklicherweise eine Klimaanlage im Arbeitszimmer und im Schlafzimmer.
Wobei ich ungern bei der Klimaanlage schlafe, wenn die an ist.
Ich mache die meistens an und wenn es dann schön kühl ist, mache ich die aus und dann penne ich eine Runde.
Und wenn es mir dann wieder zu warm wird, mache ich die wieder an und dann mache ich die wieder aus.
Aber im Arbeitszimmer lasse ich mir unter mir den ganzen Tag laufen.
Wobei ich da jetzt auch dazu übergegangen bin.
Ich mache die gar nicht mehr so kalt, das ist auch dumm. Ich habe die jetzt auf 25 Grad stehen im Schlafzimmer auf 26 Grad. Das wird schon so ein halbes Grad kühler oder so, aber das reicht. Das reicht. Ich meine draußen ist es 37 Grad oder so was, dann am Mittag wieder oder an die 40 Grad und drinnen ist es sonst auch so 30 Grad. 30,5 hatten wir gestern Abend im Schlafzimmer.
und diese 5-6 Grad
kühler machen es einfach richtig aus.
Das ist von
man hält es nicht aus zu easy.
Generell ist Klimaanlagen
eine Überlegung wert.
Also das wird ja die nächsten Jahre
nicht besser. Das wird die nächsten Jahre
eher noch schlechter.
Naja, Klimaanlagen ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll.
Und es gibt ja mittlerweile auch, wenn man in der Miete wohnt, gibt es ja ein paar Dinger, das habe ich so am Rande verfolgt.
Also es gibt diese ganz normalen Splittgeräte, wo man Schlauch quasi am Fenster festmachen muss.
und es gibt so welche, habe ich jetzt auch gesehen, mit einem richtigen Außengerät,
die macht man so ans Fensterbrett fest oder am Balkon.
Also sprich, man muss dafür nichts so baulich am Haus verändern.
Das habe ich auch letztens in einem Video gesehen.
Aber klar, das Problem hast du immer noch, du musst den Schlauch irgendwie durchbekommen.
und
finde ich auf jeden Fall sinnvoll, Alter,
ich bin eh der Meinung, Vermieter sollten
sich wirklich nicht dagegen wehren,
Klimaanlagen einzubauen, weil
du wirst in Zukunft
in Deutschland wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr so gut ohne Klimaanlage
auskommen, ich meine, überleben wirst du es immer,
wobei, kommt drauf an, ja,
guckt euch mal an, alte, kranke Leute
mit irgendwelchen Vorerkrankungen,
Immunproblem, whatever, keine Ahnung,
was da alles Risikogruppe ist.
Da gibt es ja auch Leute, die sterben wegen der Hitze.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass jetzt jeder zweite umfällt
oder so, man muss ja auch nicht übertreiben, aber
ganz ungefährlich ist es nicht.
Also sollte schon
mal in
Erwägung gezogen werden, so eine Klimaanlage.
Zumal
man kann, hat glaube ich irgendjemand auch im Chat
auch gerade geschrieben,
ich sehe es hier gerade nicht, man kann damit
im Winter sogar kühlen.
äh, nicht kühlen, wärmen, heizen.
Ja.
Ach, der Wintergrafik hat er jetzt meistens...
Ne, die meisten Klimaanlagen, also die...
Ich weiß nicht, wie das bei dieser Porta-Split aussieht oder so, keine Ahnung.
Aber die meisten Klimaanlagen, die man sich so sonst einbaut,
also die fest installiert sind, die können heizen und kühlen.
Also meine Klimaanlage hier, die hat glaube ich drei verschiedene Modi.
Die hat, ich kann es jetzt nicht drücken, weil ansonsten schalte ich um
Die hat so einen Auto-Modus
Der macht halt je nachdem, was für Temperatur eingestellt ist, Heizen oder Kühlen, das habe ich nicht
Die hat Kühlen, die hat Heizen
Die hat so einen Anti-Pollen-Modus
Da wird die Luft irgendwie so elektrisiert oder sowas
wie wenn die da durchgeht und das
das fackelt irgendwie
die Pollen ab in der Luft oder so.
Fragt mich nicht, wie das, das habe ich noch nie benutzt.
Und so einen Lüftungsmodus,
wo wahrscheinlich einfach nur Luft
ausgetauscht wird.
Ja, Anrecht auf Einbau finde ich
auch problematisch. Letztendlich gehört
das den Leuten nicht. Aber ich finde, Vermieter
sollten sich nicht dagegen sträuben.
Wenn man damit heizen kann,
gibt es Förderung. Wirklich?
Meinst du, ich könnte Förderung beantragen?
Jetzt nachträglich noch?
Geht das? Weil ich hab die ja schon
ein paar Jahre. Ich hab da keine
Förderung für beantragt, obwohl die heizen kann.
Kann ich das nachträglich noch machen?
Krieg ich nochmal Geld
wieder für meine Klimaanlage?
es wäre auch nice
nachträglich okay
CDU hat die Förderung abgeschafft, weiß ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung. Kann schon sein.
Die haben ja aktuell
ein gutes Händchen für,
so gut wie jeden abzufacken.
Die machen
Abfuck360.
Verstehe ich, ja.
Wobei du wahrscheinlich auch so schon genug Miete aktuell verlangen kannst.
Aber gerade im Dachgeschoss wirst du es doch aktuell überhaupt nicht aushalten.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Ich meine, wenn da die Sonne drauf scheint, ist es da keine Ahnung, 37 Grad oder 40 Grad, weil staut sich ja auch die Luft drin.
ich überlege gerade ja ist auch so ist auch so
letztens hat mir eine oft wird der da so ein bild geschickt so als ein klimaanlagen
hater hat mir ein bild geschickt und zwar
Ja, haben ein Bild geschickt, dass es keine gute Idee ist, eine Klimaanlage einzubauen, weil eine Klimaanlage die Erde mehr aufheizt, als sie kühlt.
Ich meine, das ist logisch, ja, dass du unterm Strich mehr Energie brauchst, das ist klar.
Aber da musst du halt an anderer Stelle gucken.
Ich glaube nicht, also erstens glaube ich nicht, dass meine Klimaanlage das Weltklima jetzt so krass zerstört, dass es Probleme gibt.
Ja, ich weiß, da kommt das Argument, ja, aber wenn das jeder macht, wenn das jeder macht, müssen wir an anderer Stelle gucken, dass wir was einsparen.
Es kann ja nicht das Sinn und Zweck sein, dass es allen Leuten im Sommer scheiße geht.
Also das schockt mich jetzt nicht so sehr.
Ja, genau.
Eins muss man ja sagen.
Eins muss man sagen, also
bei mir auf der Arbeit
ist das Klima
im Büro wirklich super.
Also die haben da noch ein bisschen mehr Möglichkeiten.
Also meine Klimaanlage hier,
da, weiß nicht
manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, es ist ein bisschen zu trocken
es zieht ein bisschen und sowas
je nachdem wie man die Klimaanlage einstellt
aber
auf der Arbeit haben die ja ganz andere Möglichkeiten
da haben die ja ein ganzes Stockwerk, was quasi nur Klimaanlage
ist und sowas
und das ist wirklich angenehm, da ist immer
da ist irgendwie so, keine Ahnung
24 Grad oder so im Büro, je nachdem was
da eingestellt ist und das ist halt
sehr angenehm
weil die haben da eine viel
größere Fläche
weiterer Grund, hups, jetzt bin ich am Mikrofon gekommen,
weiterer Grund, warum ich aktuell tatsächlich
ganz gerne nach Frankfurt fahre.
Ja, aber
ist doch egal, wie das ist. Die werden schon,
also rein rechnerisch, werden die
Recht haben. Aber es gibt trotzdem keine
Alternative dazu, zu Klimaanlagen.
Was willst du machen? Kühler?
Also selbst wenn jetzt alle schwitzen
würden, kühler wird
das garantiert nicht mehr.
Also musst du gucken, dass du es woanders einsparst,
so dass du die Klimaanlagen
einbauen kannst.
Ich habe letztens ein Video gesehen,
wurde mir empfohlen, so ein Shorts-Video auf YouTube
wurde mir empfohlen, wenn man einen Ventilator hat,
dann soll man den Ventilator
ans Fenster stellen
und umdrehen, sodass die warme Luft
rausgepustet wird und nicht die
kühle Luft rein.
Keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich stimmt.
Klingt erstmal logisch, ja.
Aber es gibt ja auch zig Tipps, so nach dem Motto, nasses Handtuch aufhängen und Ventilator dagegen pusten lassen.
Wobei ich da auch mich frage, ob das wirklich was bringt.
Weil Luftfeuchtigkeit macht das ja alles noch schlimmer.
Ja, hohe Luftfeuchtigkeit ist heftig
Ich muss gerade mal kurz in meinen Home Assistant gucken, wo wir gerade dabei sind
Was wir aktuell für eine Temperatur haben
Wir haben jetzt schon 28,89 Grad
Wisst ihr auch, was richtig gute Investition war?
Ich habe so eine Wetterstation
Ich bin mir nicht sicher mal wie dieses Ding hieß
Aber ich hab mir so eine
Privat, Quatsch nicht so ein Ding, so ein Ding hier
Sowas in der Richtung
Keine Ahnung ob es exakt das hier ist
Aber sowas in der Richtung hab ich mir gekauft
Und das ist wirklich extrem nice
Du siehst genau
Also das ist zum ersten Mal
So ein Außentemperatursensor
Auf den ich mich tatsächlich verlasse
Früher hatte ich immer so ein Billigding
Aus-Temperatur-Sensor
Dann hast du noch ganz gut, wie windig es ist
Du hast, ob es regnet, beziehungsweise wie viel
Wobei das Ding nicht wirklich gut dafür ist, zu checken, ob es nur nieselt
Weil es erst ab einem gewissen Regeneinfall hier so überhaupt funktioniert
Aber das finde ich mega praktisch, das Teil
Anyone here know about PCs?
I only know about PCs when I want to buy a new one.
So I am currently a big noob.
Das einzige was ich weiß ist, dass die Storage sehr teuer ist.
Richtig teuer und riesig teuer und die Erinnerung ist extrem teuer.
Mein PC ist bereits, ich denke, über drei Jahre alt.
Dezember 2020.
Drei und ein halbes Jahr alt.
Aber es ist immer noch gut.
progression in hardware speed ist noch nicht so hoch. Es war viel höher in den 90ern und
frühen 2000ern. Man musste ein neues PC jedes 2 Jahre kaufen, weil das alte suckte.
Ja, ey, kann man sich kaum vorstellen, oder? PC ist dreieinhalb Jahre alt und immer noch
high end das hätte früher nicht gegeben auf gar keinen fall es hätte früher nicht gegeben dass
ein high end pc nach dreieinhalb jahren immer noch nicht high end plus beste was es gibt sondern
immer noch high end ist ja 13.900 k und 40 90 ist immer noch besser als 90 prozent der leute an pcs
haben
oh i have absolutely no clue
but maybe maybe maybe it's too hot in germany it's um around 40 degrees
celsius
Ja.
Na gut, war das nicht letztens so,
dass sogar AMD gesagt hat,
dass sie jetzt wieder alte CPUs rausbringen,
die wieder alten RAM unterstützen?
Oder war doch AMD, oder?
Die bringen wieder AM4-Sachen, glaube ich, raus.
Alte CPUs,
der alten RAM unterstützt,
weil der neue so teuer ist.
War doch irgendwie was, oder?
Dass die wieder alte CPUs
herstellen.
Ja, hier, ah ne.
Genau, genau, das hier meine ich doch.
Neue alte Ryzens für Rechner
mit billigem DDR4-RAM.
Also das hätte es früher auch nicht gegeben, ey.
Sag ich euch. Das hätte es früher wirklich nicht gegeben.
Dass wieder angefangen wird,
alte CPUs zu produzieren.
Keine Ahnung, so 2000
rum. Nach zwei Jahren
konntest du den Rechner wegschalten. Ich weiß noch, als ich
Far Cry 1 spielen wollte,
Sorry, I don't talk about the red CPU light problem.
Just talk about AMD CPUs.
Sorry, I cannot help you.
No idea.
Maybe you can google it.
Mit den Mainboards, Namen und CPU.
Wenn es ein gemeinsames Problem ist, sind es vielleicht Reddit-Posts.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Eine Sache die man versuchen kann ist, wenn man mehrere Banken RAM hat, vielleicht ist die RAM nicht effektiv,
Man kann es einfach mit einem Banken probieren und die Slots wechseln, um zu sehen, ob einer der RAM-Banken die RAM-Module verpasst hat.
Wie viel hat man damals für einen High-End-PC bezahlt?
Ziemlich genau 2000 Mark.
Ziemlich genau 2000 Mark hat man damals für High-End-PCs bezahlt, eine ganze Weile lang.
Und danach so um die 1000, bisschen über 1000 Euro.
Das waren wirklich gute PCs, ne?
Also ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, als ich damals noch zum Mediamarkt gefahren bin.
Da habe ich übrigens mal ein Video zu gemacht.
Das will ich jetzt nicht hier nochmal erzählen.
Mediamarkt.
Oh Gott, warum übersetzen die meine Videos?
Warum übersetzen die meine Videos, Alter?
Damals bin ich mit meinem Vater zum Mediamarkt gefahren.
Um mir einen PC zu kaufen.
Das war ein Pentium 2.
400.
Ich bin mir nicht mal sicher, wie viel RAM.
Hups.
Moment, jetzt habe ich den Chat zugemacht auf meinem Vorschau-Rechner.
Sekunde.
Ich...
Alter, Phobis ist der letzte Rotzlan.
Die sind bei mir durch.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es die überhaupt noch gibt.
Zumindest...
War das ein Pentium 2 400 mit? Ich weiß es nicht. Wie viel RAM hatte man damals? 32 MB? Nee, wahrscheinlich 128 MB oder sowas. Ja, genau, das war die Story. Du hast das Video also geguckt, ja.
Ja.
Zumindest habe ich damals
dann den PC gekauft
und danach habe ich mir noch
eine
Lieder gekauft.
Das war die erste
Nvidia TNT Grafikkarte.
Also die erste Nvidia
Grafikkarte, die ich hatte damals.
Das war
ein
Nvidia Riva TNT
1998.
Passiv gekühlte Grafikkarte
damals noch.
Die Fische leben noch, ja.
Passiv gekühlte Grafikkarte.
Wobei man da schon damals auch auf guten Airflow achten musste.
Natürlich nur VGA-Ausgang
und sowas. Das Ding war damals wirklich
das schnellste, was es gab.
Und es hat, glaube ich, damals
250 Schmack gekostet.
Die Grafikkarte.
Und man hat sich gedacht,
Boah, Alter, 250 Mark für eine extra Grafikkarte.
WTF?
Aber das war das Beste, was es damals gab.
Da hatte ich ein Pentium 2, 400
und eine
TNT 1 Grafikkarte.
Und das war in Kombination... Also du hättest es
damals nur noch toppen können,
wenn du noch zusätzlich eine
Voodoo 2 SLI gehabt hättest.
Was ich zu der Zeit gespielt habe...
Irgendwie 65 Mal
Half-Life durchgespielt auf jeden Fall.
Also Half-Life habe ich durchgespielt
und habe dann wieder von vorne angefangen.
Was hast du heute vor?
Ich muss heute noch...
Ich weiß, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht das, was du wissen willst,
aber es fällt mir gerade ein.
Ich muss heute noch 45 Minuten
langsamer Ausdauerlauf,
oder wie man das nennt, auf Deutsch machen.
In meiner Garmin-Watch heißt es einfach nur Base
Das wird witzig
45 Minuten
Bei 38 Grad
Da kann ich
Da kann ich mich ein bisschen
Nachfühlen, wie sich die Ironman-Leute
In Frankfurt gerade fühlen
Aber was gab es für Games
Also es gab in dem Dreh
Ist das eine gute Idee
Nee, das ist keine gute Idee.
Ich muss...
Na, zu trinken nehme ich nichts mit.
Ich hau mir einfach vorher massig Wasser rein.
Bei 45 Minuten muss ich nichts mitnehmen.
Ich trinke einfach vorher irgendwie 2 Liter oder so.
Dann schwabbelst du zwar ein bisschen im Bauch.
Ja, du hast recht.
Du hast recht.
Ich hab so eine...
Ich hab so eine Weste.
Da kann man so Beutel reinstecken.
Die hab ich erst zweimal angehabt.
Als es so heiß war.
Kennt ihr das vielleicht? Das ist so eine Weste, da kann man so, das sieht so aus wie kleine Plastiktüten.
Kann man da so Wasserbeutel reinstecken.
Also muss man keine Flasche mitnehmen, weil Flaschen so unhandlich sind.
Games 1998, also lass mich mal, ich erinnere mich auf jeden Fall in dem Dreh daran.
Diablo 2, Starcraft und Half-Life.
Quake 3,
Unreal Tournament,
ähm,
Counter-Strike später dann,
so in dem Dreh.
Es gab's ja noch so viele Games,
da gab's jede Menge. Age of Vampires,
ja.
Baldur's Gate,
genau.
Wir reden ja hier nur PC, PC-Games.
Doch war auch,
aber, ähm,
Die besten PC Games
1998, okay Half-Life
Eindeutig
Was?
Golfspieler
WTF NHL
Frankreich 98, die Fußball-WM
Damals hieß es noch nicht mal FIFA
Unreal auf jeden Fall
Unreal kam vor Half-Life raus
War der Grafik
Blender schlechthin, finde ich
Ich muss ehrlich sagen
Also, ich bin der Meinung, Unreal war das beste Singleplayer-Unreal, was es gegeben hat.
Gab ja nicht so viel.
Unreal 2 hat gesagt, grafisch war das für die damalige Zeit mega geil.
Aber Half-Life war das eindeutig bessere Game.
Meiner Ansicht nach.
Half-Life sah zwar nicht so geil aus wie Unreal.
Aber Half-Life war das deutlich bessere Game.
Starcraft.
Grimm von Dango, das kenne ich.
Thief.
Dark Project.
Genau, genau, genau.
Das war auch nice.
Siedler 3.
Da kann ich mich noch dunkel dran erinnern.
Ja.
Guckt euch mal an.
Damals ist man komplett ausgeflippt.
Wenn man sich
das hier angeguckt hat.
Das war damals hier massive, huge
Graphics.
Da ist man ausgeflippt hier.
So geil sah das aus.
Ohne Scheiß hier.
Glaub mir, Leute.
Für 1998 war das die geilste Grafik ever.
Warcraft 3 habe ich ganz vergessen.
Aber das kam ein bisschen später, glaube ich.
Das war richtig geil.
Und ich finde, atmosphärisch sieht das immer noch gut aus.
Und damals, was ich damals...
Guck mal, das, by the way, das waren übrigens die Anfänge der Unreal Engine, ne?
Das war der Unreal Editor damals.
So sah das damals aus.
Unreal Engine 1.0.
Das hier, da...
da ging einem damals richtig was ab bei.
Als man das gesehen hat hier.
Hier.
Ich meine,
wenn ihr euch da mal reinversetzt,
1998, ne?
Ich finde, das sieht heute auch immer noch
recht stimmungsvoll aus.
Ich meine, es sieht sehr kantig aus im Vergleich zu heute.
Aber ich finde, es sieht immer noch
halbwegs stimmungsvoll aus.
Und bei dem Wasser ist man
damals auch komplett ausgeflippt, ja.
Das war doch ohne Spiegelung oder
irgendwas. Von irgendwelchen
Shadern hat damals keiner geredet.
Aber da ist man
damals voll drauf abgegangen.
Boah, sieht das geil aus.
Beleuchtungseffekte.
Und wo ich mich
voll erschreckt habe
damals. Und es lief flüssig.
Es lief flüssig auch auf nicht
Ultra-Mega-High-End-Hardware.
Und wo ich mich damals voll erschreckt habe, ich weiß nicht, ob es dazu...
Ob es dazu nen...
...nen Video gibt?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich sagen soll.
Corridor Lines?
Das kannst du hier nicht suchen, der Unreal 1, gescheit.
Da gab es so ne...
Ist es das? Das könnte es sein.
Nee.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Es gab so eine Szene in Unreal 1.
Da bist du einen Gang lang gelaufen.
In dem Gang waren Lichter.
Und als du dann am Ende von dem Gang warst, sind die Lichter ausgegangen.
Und es hat so gruselige Geräusche gegeben.
Da hab ich mir damals fast in die Hose gemacht.
Das ist für
Half-Life, der Editor.
Ja gut, früher hieß der Half-Life, also
der Half-Life-Editor hieß früher
Worldcraft Half-Life.
Half-Life Worldcraft.
So hat man damals für Half-Life-Level gebaut.
gab sogar noch eine cd heute heute heißt der hammer früher ist der worldcraft
der roller coaster tycoon ist verrückt er hat es voll übertrieben
Welches Game?
Also ich habe 1998
höchstwahrscheinlich eine Mischung gespielt aus
Half-Life und immer noch Diablo 2
Weil Lord of Destruction
kam glaube ich 1997
Oh fuck, was?
Bin ich so
durcheinander im Kopf?
Anscheinend
Wann kam denn Diablo 2 raus?
Nicht Destiny 2, Alter.
Diablo 2 war 1999 dann, oder?
2000 kam das erst raus.
Ha!
Das ist immer.
Jetzt war ich durcheinander im Kopf.
Naja, so.
Genug
Max-Erzähl-vom-Krieg-Stories.
Guck mal, was auf GitHub so trendet.
Bungie geht gerade den Bach runter.
Das hab ich mitbekommen, ja. Die haben auch irgendwie ganz viele Leute
entlassen.
Wie alt war ich?
1998? Jaja, das war meine Schulzeit.
Da war ich 14.
da haben wir damals mit
erst mit 0 Modem Kabel
uns zusammengestöpselt
zwei Rechner zusammen
mit 0 Modem Kabel
und später hatten wir dann ein Netzwerk
mit BNC Kabel
also
Hubs und Switches
hatte man damals noch nicht
CS gab es dann später
Half-Life kam 1998, CS kam dann ein Jahr später oder sowas.
Es war aber dann noch 05.2 und sowas.
2000.
Ja, auch so in dem Dreh.
Auch so in dem Dreh, aber wie gesagt
Mit BNC-Netzwerk-Karten damals noch
Also mit BNC-Netzwerk
Was war das?
10 Base 2, gell?
10 Base 2 hieß das doch, glaube ich, oder?
Jaja, genau
Mit den Kabel und den
Jaja, genau, genau
How to build
Genau
Die haben mich damals richtig krass verarscht
Ich war in so einem Geschäft drinnen
Und wollte mir ein Netzwerk
Das habe ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt
Und wollte mir ein Netzwerk kaufen
Oh, das kenne ich auch noch
Das kenne ich auch noch
Das ist so ein 3D
Wir fliegen durch Gänge Spiel
Super verwirrendes Level Design
Du weißt überhaupt nicht, wo du hin musst
Das kenne ich mich aber auch noch
Möglich, möglich
Ja
Wirklich
Zumindest, die haben mich damals super verarscht
Als ich mir eine Netzwerkkarte kaufen wollte
Ich wollte mir damals eine Netzwerkkarte kaufen
Bin in so einen kleinen PC-Laden gegangen
Und
Da haben die mir damals
Eine Netzwerkkarte aus der Raumfahrt verkauft
Und ich war voll begeistert
Weil das angeblich
Eine Netzwerkkarte aus der Raumfahrt war
Die haben halt gesagt, die wird auch in der Raumfahrt
eingesetzt. Ich so, boah, Alter, das muss
aber geil sein. Eine Netzwerkkarte
aus der Raumfahrt.
Die haben mich richtig verarscht.
Das war die übelste, das war ohne Scheiß,
das war die beschissenste Netzwerkkarte,
die ich jemals hatte. Das war so
ein Crap-Texting, Alter.
Das ging immer zwischendurch
nicht. Die NASA-Netzwerkkarte,
ja. Das war übelst, das war
wirklich der letzte Rotz an Netzwerkkarten.
Das war die schlechteste Netzwerkkarte, die ich je hatte.
Die wissen schon, warum die die mit so einem Blödsinn verkauft haben
Sonst hätte die wahrscheinlich keiner gekauft
Ja, das war die schlechteste Netzwerkkarte ever
Und man musste damals hier
So wie der da
Du musstest, ich vielleicht mal gucken
Switch, Moment, Moment, Moment
Hat der allen ernstes
Alter, der hat einen Switch
Oder einen Hub, keine Ahnung
mit, mit
Koax-Stecker. Das habe ich ja noch nie gesehen.
Habt ihr sowas schon mal gesehen?
Krass Zeug, Alter.
Zumindest...
Ja, habt ihr schon gesehen, okay.
Zumindest, was man damals
auch noch machen musste hier.
Du musstest damals in die
Netzwerkumgebung gehen, oder in das,
in die Netzwerk-Settings
musstest du damals gehen,
damit du spielen konntest. Du musst so viel Mist
einschalten unter Windows. Du musstest
TCP-IP erstmal aktivieren,
da musstest du IPX, SPX
oder wie das heißt, aktivieren,
NetBIOS, NetBOI,
NetBOI über TCP-IP,
Alter, das war ein Krampf zum
einrichten. Und dann hast du Glück
und konntest mit anderen Rechnern im Netzwerk kommunizieren.
Weil Half-Life
ursprünglich, wenn ich das noch richtig im Kopf hatte,
lief nicht über TCP-IP,
Half-Live lokaler Multiplayer lief über
IPX glaube ich
Erst später gab es mit einem Patch
TCP IP Mode
Max schau auf die Tastatur
Mit komischem
Trackball
Half-Live Multiplayer
Ja, das war schon eine nice Zeit.
Und wisst ihr, also ich werde mich nicht dazu hinreißen,
dass du sagst, oh, das war damals besser.
Das war garantiert nicht besser.
Aber die Zeit hatte damals für mich eine gewisse Begeisterung,
die ich heute bei solchen Sachen nicht mehr verspüre.
Also heute ist es wirklich selten, dass mich irgendwas begeistert.
Also so technikmäßig.
dass ich so sag, boah, alter, geil, ne 5090 RTX, alter, ich flip aus oder so.
Damals bin ich da bei dem ganzen neuen Zeug komplett ausgerastet immer.
Heute eher weniger.
Ja, heute released Nintendo ne neue Konsole und ich denk mir, ach, weißt du was,
kauf's dir besser nicht, Nintendo hat eh immer so wenig Spiele.
Damals hast du das einfach blind gekauft, bist du übrigens ausgeflippt.
Als ich einen N64 bekommen habe, bin ich wahrscheinlich ausgeflippt wie das Nintendo 64-Kit.
Kennt ihr dieses Video?
Nintendo 64!
Kennt ihr die hier?
Aber man hört gar nicht, wie der rumschreit.
Warte mal.
Der ist voll!
Oh mein Gott!
Der ist komplett am eskalieren!
Ich glaube, die sind aufgeregt!
Der ist ja komplett am durchdrehen, Alter!
Ja, ungefähr so muss ich damals auch rausgeflippt sein.
Nintendo 64.
Heute denke ich mir,
ah, Nintendo bringt die Switch raus
oder Switch 2.
Ich kaufe mir das Ding erstmal nicht.
Es kommen eh so wenig geile Games.
Blablabla.
Naja.
Damals hat mich doch deutlich mehr noch begeistert.
Ich finde, es ist auch weniger Begeisterung
in der ganzen Sache heute drin.
Das liegt sicherlich daran, dass ich viele schon gesehen habe, wenn ich ein bisschen älter bin, aber irgendwie ist es auch weniger begeistert.
Damals, wisst ihr, heute, heute die ganzen Pressekonferenzen, ja, jedes zweite Wort ist super excited, dass sie gehypt sind und so excited und überhaupt.
Die hypen immer auf ihrer Pressekonferenz das ganze Zeug hoch wie verrückt, aber man spürt von dem Hype überhaupt nichts.
Tokens gleich Profit
Man spürt da überhaupt nichts von
Damals haben die irgendeinen Trailer gezeigt
Und nix gehypt
Und du bist komplett ausgerastet, weil du den Trailer gesehen hast
Ja, keine Ahnung, was Nintendo da treibt
Also ich bin ja der Meinung
Nintendo Konsolen lohnt sich
In den letzten Jahren über schon nicht mehr
Hast du irgendwie eine Handvoll gescheite
First-Party-Spiele und das war's.
Warum die Switch 2 so erfolgt?
Keine Ahnung.
Das meistgenutzte Wort ist KI.
Das stimmt.
Aktuell.
Weiß gar nicht, was kostet die Switch 2.
500 Euro.
Oh ja.
Das geht doch.
Ich meine, für das, was da in Hardware drin ist,
ist das sicherlich jetzt nichts Geilstes.
Aber
in der heutigen Zeit geht doch irgendwie noch klar.
Was ist der letzte Preis?
Ich hole Kuseng.
Kuseng ist dumm, der macht es.
So, ich muss auch mal kurz meinen Tee trinken.
Ja, das stimmt.
Es gibt durchaus noch Games, wo man das merkt.
Ja, ja, keine Frage.
Wenn auch selten.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
So, dann lassen wir uns mal gucken.
Chat, habe ich den Sellout vergessen?
Ich bin jetzt schon eine Stunde online.
Habe ich noch gar nicht selloutet?
Kann das sein?
Wo kam die Sponsoreinblendung denn?
Vorhin kam die Werbung.
Okay, naja gut, hab ich Pech gehabt.
Ich warte jetzt noch ein bisschen, bis noch ein bisschen mehr Leute da sind.
Dann mach ich noch einmal einen massive Sellout.
Ist grad schon mal...
Wir können schon mal einen kleinen Sellout machen.
Wenn ihr euch überlegt, aktuell ein NAS zu kaufen,
oder euch fragt, wo ihr eure Backups oder so ablegen sollt,
dann könnt ihr einfach mal bei mir hier auf den Link klicken im Kanal.
Da kommt ihr bei einem Alternate, beim Wubblos Alternate Shop raus.
Da gibt es aktuell relativ günstig Festplatten und Ucrean-NAS-Geräte.
Mir persönlich wäre das NAS hier am liebsten, weil das eine x86-Kiste ist.
Das andere ist auch vollkommen ausreichend für Einsteiger-Sachen, ist allerdings ein Armgerät.
Vielleicht kann man da nicht alles drauf laufen lassen, was man will.
Ich würde zu dem hier greifen.
Das ist eine relativ low-power 4-Kern-Intel-CPU.
zog das hier stimmt übrigens nicht, 2,5
Gig Netzwerk.
Die CPU hat Crypto
Extensions und ich glaube QuickSync.
Ich glaube. Müsst ihr nachgucken. QuickSync.
Und das heißt, ihr könnt damit halbwegs
transcoden und
die Festplatten oder Sachen verschlüsselt haben.
Und ihr müsst trotzdem 2,5 Gig
ausgelastet bekommen.
Also ich finde, das ist ein gutes Bundle.
Und zumindest das NAS ist ein gutes NAS.
Für den Preis.
Wandel müsst ihr mal gucken hier, ob euch das ausreicht.
Ansonsten könnt ihr euch einfach nur die Festplatten kaufen hier günstig und das NAS dann woanders.
Es gibt leider kein 4-Bay-NAS.
Das ist aber so, Alternate hat ja auch die anderen Geräte.
Aber die sind halt nicht vergünstigt oder günstiger.
Denn die Preise hier gelten nur über meinen Chat.
Äh.
Über meinen Chat, über meinen Link.
Nicht über meinen Chat.
also gelten nur über den link den ihr im chat oder im profil findet leider leider
kein kein vorbein als ich müsste ich müsste da echt mal sagen leute wo wir
nicht das nächste mal vorbein sponsoring machen weil ich finde die
vorbein asses sind für etwas advanced anwendungsgebiete gar nicht so verkehrt
Gerade wenn man noch ein bisschen mehr CPU-Leistung braucht oder wenn man beispielsweise noch ein paar SATA-SSDs reinmachen will oder tatsächlich vier Festplatten, falls man RAID 6 machen will.
Ein RAID 6 mit vier Festplatten ist auch so ein Ding.
Weiß nicht.
Aber kann man machen.
Also unter vier Festplatten kann man kein RAID 6 machen.
Festplattenpreise sind richtig krass mittlerweile.
Deswegen ist es eigentlich ganz gut,
dass es hier diesen Sponsored-Link gibt,
weil die Festplattenpreise sind hier wenigstens
ein bisschen günstiger, als wenn ihr sonst guckt.
Leider,
das müsste ich hier vielleicht auch mal...
Es wäre gut, wenn die vielleicht noch eine 20TB-Platte
oder eine 24TB-Platte
oder zumindest eine 16-18TB-Platte
anbieten würden. Wobei das hier auch schon 8TB
mit 8TB kann man auch schon
was anfangen. So ist das nicht.
Und die gibt es hier über den Link relativ günstig.
Und wie gesagt hier nur über den Link
in dem Shop. Sonst ist es teurer.
Ich muss mir einen super ergonomischen
Bürostuhl kaufen. Hast du einen? Ja mach mal Ausrufezeichen
Stuhl. Aber
ich kann
gleich
die Preise über deinen Link sind dieselben wie sonst.
Das kann überhaupt nicht sein.
Die haben mir extra per Mail geschrieben, ich soll sagen, die Preise gibt es nur über meinen Link.
Und dementsprechend ist das vollkommen ausgeschlossen, dass diese Preise normal auch so sind.
Genau, den Stuhl habe ich hier.
Da musst du dich aber festhalten, der ist relativ teuer.
Ich habe nämlich einen
Sedus Mr.24
Cool
Das Problem dabei ist
Dass der auch gerne mal
Wenn du den
Neu in der Konfiguration kaufst
Wie du möchtest
Auch mal gerne über 1500 Euro kostet
Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen
iWolf und iWolf Pro
Ich vermute, ich rate jetzt
Ich rate jetzt, ne
Ich vermute mal, dass sie sagen, sie garantieren
Für längere Zeiten, wo die läuft
Und wahrscheinlich wird die Fehlerrate
Ein bisschen geringer sein
Rate ich jetzt einfach mal, ich hab keine Ahnung
Wollen wir mal, komm wir fragen mal die China KI
Ob sie das weiß
Was sagt
Was sagt die China KI
Die China KI sagt, dass sie kaputt ist, geil
Okay
Was ist der Unterschied
zwischen ein wolf und ein wolf ist geil china k ist kaputt perfekt ok dann frage
perplexity oder wir fragen da gibt ja mittlerweile genug zur auswahl
Okay, genau. Höhere jährliche Arbeitslast.
Das ist das, was ich schon gesagt habe.
Längere Garantie.
Von Fehlerrate steht hier nichts.
Okay.
größerer cash wir vertrauen einfach jetzt mal dass die ki das weiß das ist
speicherkapazität ist schon mal gelogen das schon mal blödsinn
ok höhere dass das habe ich gemeint er nervt also ist im prinzip das was ich
gesagt habe das heißt wenn du nass daheim baust was 24 7 läuft und länger
garantie haben willst lohnt sich der aufpreis eventuell für dich das die pro
variante zu kaufen weil die muss ja nur eine festplatte in 55 jahren kaputt
gehen hast den preis schon wieder drin
das ding ist halt du kannst auch so machen wie ich und schockst dir eine
sie geld festplatte hast du keine garantie und wenn die kaputt geht hast
du quasi dadurch dass sie den neuen kauf muss mehr bezahlt als hätte die
normale mit Garantie gekauft.
Würdest du das
im Raid laufen lassen?
Was jetzt? Mit den Siegelplatten?
Mit den Einwolfplatten?
Ja, würde ich.
Also wenn ich
ein Nass hätte mit mehr als 2.
Mit mehr als 2.
Achso, im 2-Bay.
Ja, würde ich auch.
Also ich würde wahrscheinlich ein Raid 1
machen.
Also wenn ich jetzt nicht so sehr aufs Geld gucken müsste.
Ja, also ich muss, okay, dann beantworte ich das mal in zwei Stimmen.
Wenn ich nicht so sehr aufs Geld gucken müsste und mir wirklich wichtig wäre, dass das auch wirklich 24-7 läuft, ja.
Zum Beispiel, weil nicht nur ich der einzige Benutzer bin, sondern die Familie das noch mitbenutzt oder sowas.
Dann würde ich ein RAID 1 machen.
Ja, du kannst auch ein ZFS RAID 1 machen, das ist egal.
RAID 1, Mirror, ja, Mirror.
Wie auch immer du den Mirror machst, ist burscht.
und dann würde ich mir nochmal eine Platte extern per USB dranhängen,
wo ich nächtlich drauf Airsynke oder mit irgendeiner Backup-Software drauf backupe,
weil man darf immer nicht vergessen, RAID ist gut für Ausfallsicherheit,
RAID schützt dich nicht gegen Blödsinn,
weil RAID wird dir immer alles gespiegelt auf beide Platten.
Wenn du aus Versehen eine Datei auf dem RAID löscht, ist die weg,
obwohl die vorher zweimal da war, ist die weg.
Das heißt, so ein zeitversetztes Backup auf eine externe Platte ist trotzdem sinnvolle Geschichte
Und wenn ich will, wie gesagt zum Beispiel, weil die Familie das benutzt, weil da irgendwelche Linux-Distributionen von gestreamt werden, dann würde ich sagen RAID 1 und per externe USB-Festplatte dran und darauf Backupen per Async oder sowas einmal in der Nacht.
Da hast du ein ziemlich sicheres Setup.
Ansonsten, wenn ich aufs Geld achten müsste
Dann würde ich tatsächlich auf Raid 1 verzichten
Und würde zwei Festplatten einbauen und darauf ersinken
Also ich würde Backup dem Raid vorziehen
Weil was kann dir im schlimmsten Fall passieren?
Die eine Festplatte geht dir kaputt
Du bestellst dir bei Amazon eine neue und baust die ein und kopierst es rüber
Ja, dann bist du vielleicht mal einen Tag, ist dein NAS vielleicht mal einen Tag weg, aber wenn nur du das benutzt und da jetzt nichts wirklich krass Mission-Critical-Zeug drauf liegt, ist das im Heimbereich ohne Probleme zu verschmerzen.
Das kommt ein bisschen drauf an, was du machst, ja.
Also bei ZFS, das weiß ich jetzt aber auch nur beim Hörensagen, bei ZFS on Linux ist es wohl mittlerweile problemlos möglich, die Festplatten auszutauschen in einem ZFS-Array oder wie man das da nennt.
Das geht wohl. Du musst nach und nach die Festplatten durch eine größere ersetzen, das geht.
Also du kannst wohl, Chat, vielleicht hat das jemand von euch schon mal gemacht.
Du kannst, so von der Theorie her ist das so
Mal angenommen, du hast jetzt
Ein ZFS Mirror, wie gesagt, das ist reines
Hörensagen, ich hab das selbst noch nie gemacht, ne
Du hast jetzt ein Mirror aus
Zwei 8TB Platten, da kannst du
Sagen, du nimmst eine Platte
Detachst du aus dem Mirror
Baust dafür eine 16TB Platte ein
Lässt das wieder re-silvern
Und dann detachst du die erste Platte
Und baust eine 16TB Platte ein
Und lässt es re-silvern, dann hast du ein 16TB Mirror
Also, das muss recht problemlos mittlerweile mit ZFS und Linux funktionieren
Wann kommen wieder Videos?
Ich bin jetzt die letzten Wochen schon immer ganz kurz davor gewesen
Mal endlich wieder ein Update-Video zu machen, wie es was Sache ist, ja
Beziehungsweise was das letzte Jahr über Sache, warum ich das letzte Jahr
Das Jahr davor war im Prinzip einfach nur Arbeit und kein Bock
Das letzte Jahr hatte ich ja ein bisschen Probleme
Da wollte ich mal ein Video drüber machen
Weil ich im Chat auch gemerkt habe, es gibt ganz viele Leute, die ähnliche Probleme haben
Und ich hatte den Eindruck, dass das gerade selbst betroffene Leute auch im Chat gar nicht schlecht fanden
Da mal ein bisschen drüber von anderen Leuten zu hören
Genau so ist es, sehr gut
Also Max Stahlmann, ich kann dir wirklich nur meinen Stuhl empfehlen, den ich habe, den da
Das ist ohne Scheiß
Der beste Stuhl, den ich kenne
Guck mal, und sogar bei Bruno
Ach ne, Büro
Ich hab Bruno Goertz gelesen
Büro Goertz
Das Ding ist wirklich super
Da kannst du nichts sagen, es ist der beste Stuhl
Es gibt zwei verschiedene
Kopflänen, die da und die da
Ich hab die da
Ähm, wahrscheinlich würde ich mir heute eher die da wieder kaufen.
Das ist der beste Stuhl.
Der ist für 24 Stunden auf dem Arsch sitzen ausgelegt.
Dir tut nicht der Arsch weh.
Das Einzige, das Schlimmste, was dir passiert ist, wenn du zu schräg drinnen sitzt und zu schepp,
dass dir eine Arschbacke einschläft.
Das ist dann aber wirklich auch das, das, das...
...üchste der Gefühle.
Was macht den Stuhl besser? Keine Ahnung, ich hatte noch keinen
Hermann Miller Stuhl, aber hier kann ich aus erster Hand
sagen, sowohl von mir privat
als auch auf der alten Arbeit
da hatten wir den nämlich auch und da fand ich den so gut
dass ich mir den privat gekauft hab, dass ich
nie dran gedacht hab
mir wieder einen anderen Stuhl zu kaufen
Und außerdem hält der ewig, das Ding ist
massive stabil und
Leute, ich weiß ja, wir haben hier durchaus
ja im Chat, im Chat
auch die ein oder anderen Leute,
den hat der Krieger auch.
Dieser Krieger hat's da, kennt sich aus mit
Stühlen.
Es sind ja im Chat durchaus
auch die ein oder anderen Pipo-Fett-Kandidaten.
Der Stuhl hat, glaube ich, bis zu
250 Kilo Belastbarkeit.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Steht das da irgendwo?
Ah, bis 200 Kilo.
Bis 200 Kilo.
Okay, okay, okay, bis 200 Kilo.
Ja, und das Gute ist, was ihr bei dem auch habt, das haben bestimmt andere Stühle auch,
du hast so, du hast die Möglichkeit, dir die Sitzlehnen wirklich exakt so einzustellen, wie du willst.
Was ist denn das denn?
Achso, das ist die Feder.
Ja, du kannst die, ich weiß nicht, das zeigen die hier nicht.
Wir gehen jetzt einfach mal...
Wir gehen jetzt bei denen mal auf die Webseite.
So.
Jaja, Reject.
Alter!
Der Raum war nicht billig, Leute!
Der Raum war garantiert nicht billig.
1500 Euro pro Stuhl.
Die Webseite sieht übrigens besser aus normal.
Das ist, weil ich Dark Reader anhabe.
Was ich da wirklich sehr gut finde ist, ich hoffe die zeigen das nochmal.
Ah, Nackenstütze, bla.
Irgendwie zeigen sie die Lehnen gar nicht.
Du kannst die Lehnen von dem Stuhl, die kannst du hoch und runter verstellen, vorwärts und rückwärts und links und rechts.
Das heißt, die sind so 3D-mäßig verstellbar.
Du kannst sie wirklich exakt dahin machen, wie du willst.
Und das finde ich ganz praktisch, weil ich habe die linke Stuhllehne lieber ein bisschen weiter vorne und ein bisschen weiter rechts.
Und die rechte Stuhllehne ein bisschen weiter vorne rechts und vorne.
Und die linke Stuhllehne habe ich so mittige, neutrale Position.
Habe ich das lieber.
Also ich habe die Armlehne nicht exakt synchron eingestellt.
Und das ist halt...
Also wie gesagt, ich finde den Stuhl absolut top.
Und ich bin nicht sponsert von denen.
Die sollten mich mal sponsern.
Ist halt die Frage,
ist halt die Frage, ob du so viel Geld
ausgeben willst. Aber ganz ehrlich, Leute,
es gibt zwei Dinger,
wofür ich wieder so viel Geld ausgeben würde
wie jetzt. Oder wie ich
Geld ausgegeben habe.
Also es gibt bestimmt noch mehr Sachen, aber so, wenn es
hier so um Sitzen geht. Das ist
einmal mein Bürostuhl,
weil wir müssen mal uns da im
klar darüber werden, ich verdiene mein Geld mit vorm
Computer sitzen.
Und dementsprechend ist es auch
sinnvoll, bequem vorm Computer zu sitzen.
Und viele von euch verdienen auch ihr Geld mit vorm
Computer sitzen. Da ist es durchaus mal drinnen,
sich was ordentliches zu kaufen.
Ja. Die Dinger sollen ja auch nicht
schlecht sein, aber ich kann das aus erster Hand
halt nicht berichten.
Ja. Walking Pad habe ich nicht. Ich habe einen
höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch, habe ich noch. Wobei
ich den relativ selten benutze.
Was ich auch noch, wenn es auch noch um
Sitzen geht, was ich auch noch
jederzeit wieder kaufen würde,
was ich jederzeit wieder kaufen würde,
ist mein Klo.
Mein Klo würde ich auch jederzeit
wieder kaufen.
Mein Klo mit Spülung
Und Fernbedienung
Beste Leute
Guck hier
Jetzt hier wird gespült
Und bam in the bobbies
Wird mir jederzeit wieder kaufen
Wo wir gerade bei zwei Sachen sind
Und wo es ums Sitzen geht
habe ich übrigens auch gemacht tastatur ich hab ich habe im büro habe ich auch eine eigene tastatur
und zwar habe ich eine ducky one skyline mit kompletter dass dieses dieses teil nur mit nur
mit NumBlock noch dran.
Die ist auch nice.
Und eine
G502 als Maus.
Wir haben nämlich nur so eine
billige Maus und eine billige Tastatur auf der Arbeit.
Das sagt, da brauche ich
was ordentliches.
Du hast genau die gleiche. Ja, die sind echt gut, die Dinger.
Hast du mit NumBlock oder ohne NumBlock?
Umut. Ich bin ja
NumBlock-Fan.
Mir kommen nur NumBlock, also nur
Full-Size-Tastaturen
in die Tüte.
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
In Deutschland, die Deutschen
haben es halt nicht so mit Technik.
Klimaanlagen
wirst du auch, Shep, angeguckt von vielen.
Bei
modernen Klos wirst du, Shep, angeguckt
von vielen Leuten.
Teilweise wirst du ja noch bei Smart-TVs, Shep,
angeguckt von vielen Leuten.
Wir haben es da nicht so.
Mit Technik.
Die faxen auch noch viel in Deutschland.
Es gibt keine Ducky One Skyline mehr?
Wirklich nicht mehr?
Nicht Sky One.
Ducky One.
Ah, UK.
Ah, es gibt jetzt die Ducky One 3.
Okay, die sind anscheinend nicht so beliebt.
Die gibt es echt.
Die gibt es wirklich?
Nicht mehr.
Ich kann es ehrlich, die neuen sehen einfach kacke aus.
Jetzt gibt es die Tastaturen.
Was haben die denn gemacht?
Die hatten so viele geile Tastaturen.
WTF?
Fuck.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Gut, dass ich die Tastatur noch hab.
Warum?
Aber sind die dumm?
Warum stellen die das nicht mehr her?
Warum? Hä?
Das waren richtig geile Tastaturen.
Warum stellen die ihre beste Tastatur nicht mehr her?
Muss ich das in irgendeiner Art und Weise verstehen?
Die gucken aber geil zu.
Die brauchen bestimmt zu viel RAM.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Tatsächlich?
WTF?
Was? Ich habe keine Ahnung,
warum die das überhaupt, warum die das machen.
Ich habe mir damals Tastatur-Reviews angeguckt und die hat super abgeschnitten.
Deswegen habe ich mir die damals gekauft.
Wundert mich, dass es die nicht mehr gibt, weil das wirklich so war.
Ich habe keinen sonderlich aktuellen Monitor.
Ich habe einen älteren BenQ-Monitor mit 240 Hertz.
24 Zoll.
Ich glaube.
Ich glaube 24 Zoll.
also relativ klein. Oder 23,5 Zoll
oder irgendwie sowas. Ich setze aber auch
recht nah davor.
Wann OLED
wenn mir mein Monitor
zu
so outdated
vorkommt?
Die Nachfrage
war zu klein, tatsächlich. Okay, ich hab gedacht
das Ding ging weg wie geschnitten Brot, aber
anscheinend. Komisch, naja.
Kann man nix machen.
Smart TV zu Recht, warum?
Du musst ja das Smart TV vom TV nicht benutzen
Du kannst einfach beispielsweise Schild TV dran anschließen
Aber in der heutigen Zeit, ganz ehrlich
Wie willst du denn ohne Smart TV noch die ganzen Sachen gucken?
Wenn du, weil ich meine
Ein Großteil
Der, des Contents ist ja heute
Nicht mehr lineares Fernsehen, sondern
Irgendwelche Streaming-Geschichten
Da brauchst du ja 5 verschiedene Apps mittlerweile, willst du das machen ohne Smart-TV?
Oder halt ohne Android-Box
Am Fernsehen
Achso, ja das mache ich auch nicht
Ich habe dann Nvidia Shield TV seit Jahren dran
Mini PC hast du das Problem, dass du halt keine Apps
Gescheit verwenden kannst und DRM nicht unterstützt wird
Deswegen sind diese Android Boxen
Gar nicht verkehrt
Wenn du natürlich nur
selbst downgeloadete Linux-Distributionen
streamst, dann ist kein Problem.
So, gucken wir mal, was auf GitHub
trendet diese Woche.
Schon eine Stunde 23 am Schwätzen.
Also, es trendet
Open Montage
AI. Okay.
Mit Windows GDRM
sicher
Ja.
Geht da 4K
beispielsweise mit Netflix
unter Windows?
Ah, wie bedienst du das dann gescheit
vom Fernseher aus mit Fernbedienung?
Ne, ne, ich hab tatsächlich
nicht mal weiter... Ich hab das gekauft bei Audible,
aber nicht mal weiter gehört.
So, also.
AI.
DRM.
AI, AI.
AI.
Git push, no mistakes. Was ist das?
AI, oder?
Kill all the slob, raise clean PA.
AI.
AI, AI, AI.
Ne.
PenPod.
PenPod App.
Oh, MonkaS.
Was ist das hier?
Okay, irgendeine...
So Try-O oder sowas in der Richtung.
AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, kein AI.
Ey geil super perfekte trends wieder zwei sachen nicht
Da das ja nicht so spannend gewesen so was haben wir denn hier lass mal gucken was trendet bei
heute
wir gehen
ich muss mich mal kurz in den flame modus begeben
Ok
Wisst ihr, was das Geile an C++-Projekten ist?
Also Geile, in Anführungszeichen.
C++-Projekte passen echt zu C++.
Weil die Projekte sind immer so komisch benannt und so komisch beschrieben,
dass ich absolut keine Ahnung habe, was das eigentlich ist.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Absolut keinen blassen Schimmer.
Woran siehst du denn, dass es ein AI-Projekt ist?
Na, weil da irgendwas von...
Okay, ich kann es dir zeigen
Hier, Pipelines, BAM, Agent, AI
MCP, AI
Coding Agents, Agent, AI
Analyse, höchstwahrscheinlich AI
Agent, AI, Agent, AI
AI im Titel schon, Voicebox, AI
Agent, AI
Agent AI
Entropic AI
AI
Prompt AI
Chat und Dings AI
Agent AI
Page AI
Flow, irgendwas mit Flow und Harness AI
AI
Daran erkennt man das
An den Schlüsselwörtern
Ich kann das mittlerweile gut per Auge kreppen
Was AI ist und nicht
So und das habe ich nicht gecheckt, was soll das bitte schön sein
Call Map, Structure from Motion
And Multi-View Stereo
Aha, alles klar
General Purpose Structure
From Motion 7
Und Multi-View Stereo MVS
Pipeline
With a Graphical and Command Line Interface
Das ist einfach so high IQ, das Projekt.
Ich lese das Intro und weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
Okay, Max, was ist das überhaupt?
Wait, what the fuck?
Ist das vielleicht Fotos zu 3D-Models?
Nee, oder?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Wirklich absolut kein Schimmer.
Kollege schwört auf die Tastatur.
Aha.
Ich weiß nicht.
Die sieht irgendwie billig aus.
Findest du nicht auch?
Die sieht aus wie so ein 15 Euro billig Plastik.
Und ich hab...
Vielleicht sieht es auch nur so aus.
Sind die Tasten kleiner?
Und warum die so fett ist, weiß ich auch nicht.
Aber kann sein, dass die gut ist.
Weiß ich nicht.
Okay, dann ist das sowas.
Aha, alles klar.
Ich habe einen Kollegen auf der Arbeit.
Auf der alten Arbeit.
Auf der letzten Arbeitgeber hatte ich einen.
Der war auch schon 60 plus oder so.
Der hatte noch ein Original.
So ein olles Ding.
Der hatte noch so ein olles IBM Keyboard.
So ein fettes.
Das sind ja heute richtig Sammlerobjekte geworden, diese Dinger.
Ram Generation PS4 Emulator Tensorflow 3 CAD DXVX
das ist hier diese Geschichte mit
ähm, genau
Vulkan Implementation
für DirectX 8, 9, 10, 11
Also die C++ Projekte
sind immer richtig pfeifert, Alter.
Leider ist die Sprache halt Dreck.
gRPC
Okay
Ich mach jetzt schnell was anderes,
Das war, sonst reg ich mich wieder auf.
Guck mal, was in Go trendet.
No Mistakes.
Das hatten wir gerade schon.
Wie Knorra.
Alles klar.
AI.
Guck, LLM.
Direkt erkannt.
AI.
FZF.
Das ist ja wirklich sowas Gutes, was trendet.
Das kennen wahrscheinlich die meisten von euch schon, denke ich mal, oder?
Chatge, wer kennt FZF und wer kennt FZF nicht?
Wenn nicht, zeige ich das mal kurz, weil das wirklich
Exzellent ist
Also ich kann jetzt da nur
An der Oberfläche kratzen
Aber FZF ist
Ja, das war ursprünglich auch nicht in Go
Die ursprüngliche Version
War in Ruby
FZF
Das originale FZF war in Ruby
Hier, guck
Kann ich dir sogar beweisen.
Äh, Tags?
Keine Ahnung.
Nehmen wir mal irgendwas ganz Altes, 0.1.
Guck hier, Ruby war das noch.
Kollege von mir hat auch so eine Aufrechtmaus.
So eine Maus, die man...
Wie heißt denn da so eine aufrechte Maus?
senkrecht maus so ein ding so ein ding
sie auch immer ganz abgedreht aus
Genau, also dann zeige ich euch mal ganz kurz, was man mit FZF machen kann.
Also zum Beispiel, hier.
Wenn ihr jetzt beispielsweise in einem Skript oder um euch die tägliche Arbeit zu erleichtern,
Irgendwo eine lange Liste habt mit Wörtern und ihr wollt da drinnen dynamisch suchen, dann ist FZF super.
Zum Beispiel, wenn wir jetzt LS mal nach FZF pipen, dann bekomme ich so eine Liste mit dem Output von LS und kann darin jetzt fuzzy suchen.
Ich kann nach Desktop suchen, ich kann aber auch nach Documents suchen mit DCS hier.
Documents. Also er findet fuzzy search mäßig alles mögliche.
Ich meine, jetzt ist natürlich ein bisschen doof das Beispiel.
Das ist ein bisschen wenig.
Hier der Output, ja.
Kannst du auch Inhalte in einer Datei suchen?
Klar, kannst du auch.
Nehmen wir mal hier zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, ZSHRC.
Das kannst du theoretisch nach FZF behalten und da drinnen suchen.
Ob das dann so geil ist, sei mal dahingestellt.
Wo ist der Unterschied zu CREP?
CREP ist ja hauptsächlich für Datei-Inhalte und für feste Strings.
Wenn du dynamisch tippen willst, ist halt FZF.
Also wenn du Fuzzy-Search machen willst.
Zum Beispiel, nehmen wir jetzt mal hier LS-LA.
Das beiteln wir jetzt nach FZF.
Stellt euch mal ein Beispiel vor, ihr wollt jetzt nach was suchen, wo ihr wisst, da steht Max drin.
Ähm, gefolgt von TMP.
So.
Dann könnt ihr das so relativ easy finden.
Und halt dynamisch.
Das heißt, hier lässt sich halt viel schneller drin als in einem Cap.
Letztendlich könnt ihr das auch alles möglich in einem Cap machen.
Wenn ihr aber nicht so genau wisst, nach was ihr sucht und erstmal ausprobieren müsst.
Wie hieß das Ding nochmal?
Ich weiß, es fängt mit Max an und dann kommt irgendwas mit IC oder so.
Ja, dafür ist das echt praktisch.
Also ich benutze das auf der Arbeit genau für eine Sache.
Und zwar, ich lade mir von unserem Ansible Hostlisten runter.
Und pipe die nach FZF.
Und benutze das dann für SSH-Verbindungen.
Also ich gebe dann hier zum Beispiel ein.
Ich habe das, bei mir heißt das Cron.
Ja, also Connection.
Da lädt sich einmal am Tag vom Ansible eine neue Hostliste runter.
und die pipe ich dann
nach FZF.
Und dann kann ich da drinnen suchen.
Und in der Hostliste
steht drinnen
Hausname, IP
und Umgebung. Das heißt, ich kann dann
sowas hier bei mir machen zum Beispiel.
Ich such
im Service, keine Ahnung,
im Storage Service such ich
was das
ähm
Nass heißt.
und für Brot.
So in der Richtung kann ich das dann eingeben bei mir.
Und dann finde ich die
sechs Kisten, die für
Nassstorage im Storage-Projekt
für produktive Storage-Kisten zuständig
sind.
Und dafür, also für,
da ist das enorm praktisch.
Man kann damit tausend Sachen machen
mit FZF. Also allein
schon, wenn ihr euch hier die
Manpage mal anguckt,
also das
könnt ihr super krass customizen.
Und das Gute ist, was ich wirklich cool finde, ist, das ist halt ein Go-Binary.
Das heißt, das Go-Binary könnt ihr überall hin kopieren und es läuft.
Auf jedem Linux-Site Kernel 2632.
Das ist halt POC.
Also wer das nicht kennt, FZF kann ich wirklich empfehlen.
Ich benutze das auf der Arbeit täglich mehrfach für SSH-Connections.
Also laufend für SSH-Connections.
ja genau für so dinge für so dinge ist perfekt so eine liste mit containern
worauf dich connect will das perfekt war so was also ist das tool ist wirklich
da ist die statische sachen ja für ins skripte einbauen ich weiß schon was ich
suchen muss dann nämlich natürlich cap aber für interaktive sachen ist fzf viel viel besser
Es gibt Leute, die benutzen das für alles, ja.
Es gibt Leute, die benutzen das beispielsweise für ihre History.
Ich meine, ist ja auch nicht verkehrt, ne.
Da könnt ihr jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, ich weiß genau, es war SSH und die IP war irgendwas mit 4-6.
Zack.
Schon habt ihr den ersten Treffer, SSH mit IP 1-4-6.
Und ihr seht, das rankt die Matches.
Das, was mehr Match steht unten, das was weniger Match steht oben.
Ist sowas auch nutzbar, wenn man WSL...
Ja, ja, unter WSL läuft das genauso.
Sag ich jetzt einfach mal.
Moin, Destiny.
Ah, guck hier, Destiny hält Ausschau noch günstig im Speicher.
Den es natürlich nur über meinen Link gibt.
Kleiner Sellout-Modus am Rande.
So, gut, also gucken wir weiter, was trendet auf GitHub.
Also wie gesagt, FZF nur zu empfehlen, Top-Projekt.
Bei mir auf der Arbeit kann nur ein einziger Linux...
LOL
Deswegen hat bei uns keiner Workstations
Der einzige bist du
Oder wie?
Also wir haben auch auf der Arbeit Windows-Rechner
Wir müssen Windows-Rechner, also Windows-Notebooks
Ja, Windows-Notebooks
beziehungsweise wir haben auch die möglichkeit und remote über citrix
einzuloggen das aber auch windows aber ich benutze
die windows kiste eigentlich nur für den terminal im fullscreen ja und für
outlook und so und teams und so geschiss ja aber alles andere geht terminal
fullscreen als ich logge mich auf eine auf eine cloud linux kiste ein terminal
fullscreen auf xv ding fertig sonst nichts
Rest gebe ich mir von Windows gar nicht.
Ja, bei uns ist es auch nicht erlaubt, was anderes als Windows zu benutzen.
Beziehungsweise könntest du gar nicht installieren, weil du nicht das BIOS-Passwort hast.
Citrix Workplace, ja, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung ist das.
Ich glaube schon.
Ich habe ja schon gefragt, ob wir nicht ein extra Notebook, ein zweites Notebook bekommen können, wo wir da Linux drauf installieren, aber wollen sie nicht.
Gibt es mittlerweile eigentlich Ersatz für X-Forwarding unter Wayland? Meines Wissens noch nicht.
Wayland ist halt
so ein typisches Projekt
wie man das
in der Projektplanung immer sieht
die ersten
80%
brauchen 20% der Zeit
die letzten 20% brauchen
80% der Zeit
Max, hast du dich mal mit
einer Windows-Admin auf der Arbeit oder laufend?
Wir haben ja auch Windows-Admins im Team
Also
Also wir haben drei Subteams.
Also quasi mein Chef hat drei, also der Teamleiter hat in seinem Team drei verschiedene Gruppen, wenn man so will.
Oder hat in seiner Gruppe drei verschiedene Teams, wie auch immer man das bezeichnen will.
Wir haben Linux, Windows, Storage.
Also ganz grob Kategorien, ja.
Linux beinhaltet natürlich noch deutlich mehr als nur Linux.
Ich mach ja den halben Tag nichts anderes als
Irgendwelche Cloud-Infrastruktur mit Terraform bauen
Und wieder abreißen und ab und zu mal was ändern
Aber ich hab glücklicherweise
Nichts mit Windows zu tun
Will ich auch nicht
Oh, 64 GB ECC-Rahmen ist nicht verkehrt.
Also gucken wir jetzt einfach mal weiter hier, was trendet.
Was, dann eine Cloud-VM?
Mit Desktop-Environment und wirklich nur ein Terminal.
Ich mach das so.
Also, ich logge mich hier von meinem Desktop auf der Arbeit per Zytrix ein.
Im Zytrix mache ich, weil es das einzige ist an gescheitem Terminal, was da drauf ist, auch wenn es sagt, mache ich MOBA Xterm auf.
Das ist halt standardmäßig vorinstalliert.
Da ist auch ein X-Server dabei.
Und dann starte ich Terminator über X-Forwarding.
Und das habe ich dann im Fullscreen und da mache ich alles drin.
terminator weil ich ein ordentliches terminal brauche mit splits und blitz und und vertical
horizontal splits zubringen und so also das mache ich in western machen western funktioniert leider
halt ohne bisschen grafik beschleunigung nicht sonst würde ich auch western benutzen es gibt
es gibt die möglichkeit noch sich desktop environment zu installieren das könnte ich
ja machen. Ich habe ja Hut auf meine Linux-Kiste.
Ich könnte mir ein Desktop-Environment installieren
und dann per RDP da drauf gehen zum Beispiel.
Das würde funktionieren. Oder per X2Go oder
irgendwie sowas. Das würde auch funktionieren, aber
ganz ehrlich, ich brauche ja nur einen Terminal.
Was brauche ich sonst noch mehr?
Ich habe noch Visual Studio
Code. Das läuft unter Windows,
lockt sich aber halt direkt per
SSH auch auf meine Linux-Kiste ein. Da kann ich dann
da editieren.
Also ich habe eigentlich nur einen Terminal
im Fullscreen und Visual Studio Code offen.
Und das ist reicht. Browser benutze ich unter Windows, Outlook und Teams benutze ich unter Windows, weil es halt nicht gescheit anders geht.
Und ansonsten, der Rest ist 90% Fullscreen Terminal auf der Linux-Kiste und Visual Studio Code PSSH auf der Linux-Kiste.
Natürlich könnte ich mir das deutlich angenehmeres Arbeiten vorstellen mit einem Mac oder mit einer Linux-Kiste.
Also ich würde ja einen Linux-Laptop vorziehen, aber Mac würde ich auch genauso gut nehmen.
kannst du Linux-artig genug einrichten, aber komm mal nicht dran und drumherum.
Bei uns auf der Arbeit, wir haben halt wieder 30 Milliarden Virenscanner drauf installiert
und hast du nicht gesehen, irgendwelche komischen Sachen, die nur unter Windows laufen?
Das ist halt so, da kannst du dich leider nicht dagegen wehren.
Aber was ich jetzt schon öfters gesehen habe, ist, dass manche Kollegen, die bringen ihr MacBook mit
und locken sie, also selbst auch wenn sie auf die Arbeit kommen,
bringen sie ihr MacBook mit, anstatt ihr Arbeitslaptop
und verbinden sich dann quasi mit dem MacBook zu Zytrix,
von der Arbeit aus, in die Arbeit.
Weil es angenehmer ist, an ihrem eigenen Notebook zu sitzen,
als an diesem bloated Windows Notebook von der Arbeit.
So sieht's aus.
So, also was trennt ihr denn jetzt auf GitHub?
FZF hatten wir, beste.
Kasa OS, hatten wir das nicht letztens
mal ausprobiert und festgestellt,
dass das eigentlich komplett
overrated, outdated, cheapated, also
komplett unsinnig ist?
Das haben wir doch letztens irgendwie
ausprobiert.
Außerdem...
Ne, heißt das jetzt nicht
Thema OS? Das war gar nichts.
Das hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Überhaupt gar nicht hat mir das gefallen.
Das haben wir letztes Mal irgendwann ausprobiert.
Ist CimaOS, CasaOS nicht das gleiche?
Da ist der Nachfolger.
Control-R macht FZF im Terminal.
Na, nur wenn du das eingerichtet hast.
Bei mir nicht.
Du kannst das in deine...
Du kannst das in deine History schreiben
und so mappen, dass deine History
standardmäßig, wenn du Ctrl-R drückst,
so aufgeht. Das kannst du machen.
Aber das hab ich nicht.
Das hab ich nicht. Ich hab hier die normale History-Suche noch.
Kann man machen.
So, Open Tofu.
Chat, ich frage mich gerade, was war eigentlich nochmal genau der Grund, warum Open Tofu entstanden ist?
Also ich weiß, dass HashiCorp hat gesagt, sie ändern die Lizenzbedingungen von Terraform.
Aber was genau war an den neuen Lizenzbedingungen denn jetzt so kacke, dass die Open Tofu gefolgt haben?
Wir haben auf der Arbeit, by the way, mittlerweile auch nur noch Open Tofu.
Kein Terraform mehr.
Kein echtes Terraform.
Was war denn an den Lizenzbedingungen nochmal so kacke, dass Open Tofu überhaupt entstanden ist?
Kann ich mich überhaupt noch mal dran erinnern?
Why Open Tofu?
Gibt's doch bestimmt so ne...
Why should I use...
Das Open Tofu Manifesto.
Das, das...
Why we fork Terraform?
After HashiCorp switched Terraform
from an open source license to a business
source license. Aha.
We asked HashiCorp to switch back.
Ja, natürlich haben die das nicht gemacht.
So, um sicherzustellen,
dass das alles noch so funktioniert.
TachyCorp hat nicht respondet und deswegen haben sie OpenTofu geforkt.
Okay.
Aha.
Also wir haben auf der Arbeit auch nur noch OpenTofu am Start.
Vector Database, das ist irgendwas für KI.
Modern Docker Management Design for Everyone.
Warum braucht man sowas?
Docker CLI, beste.
Ach nee, das ist eher sowas wie...
Wie Coolify oder sowas.
Oder was haben wir mal ausprobiert?
Doc, Doc, Doc Ploy, oder?
Doc Ploy haben wir mal ausprobiert im Stream. Kann das sein?
Ja, genau, genau.
Das ist sowas, sowas ähnliches.
Sowas in der Richtung ist es, oder?
Aber warum brauche ich ein Webinterface für Docker?
Das habe ich noch nie verstanden.
Es gab ja auch ein paar Leute, die früher immer Portainer verwendet haben.
Da hat es mir innerlich schon immer gecringed.
Auch keiner.
Das ist genauso wie die ganzen Git-GUIs.
Keiner braucht Git-GUIs.
Git-Command-Line, einzig wahre, beste
Und es ist jetzt kein dummes
Gelaber, ich meine das wirklich so
Ich sage ja manchmal sowas auch
Mit leichtem Kappa dabei, aber das meine ich
Wirklich so, Git-Command-Line ist
The way to go
Git zu verwenden
Die einzige Sache, wo ich mir was anderes gefallen lasse
Als
Git-Kommando-Zeile ist
Wirklich umfangreiche Merge-Konflikte
Oder irgendwelche History-Crafts oder sowas
Wobei selbst das...
Halbwegs...
Okay, das in dem Linux-Repo zu machen,
war vielleicht jetzt keine allzu schlaue Idee, Max.
Chat, sich den Git-Graf
malen zu lassen in dem Git-Repo
vom Linux-Körnel war keine so gute Idee,
glaube ich.
Aber guck mal.
Also sogar da geht das halbwegs
Mit grafischer Darstellung
Aber das geht natürlich schön
Für größere Merchkonflikte würde ich mir das noch gefallen lassen
Aber ansonsten braucht keiner Gitguys
Ja das verstehe ich
Wie gesagt für Merch
Das habe ich ja gesagt
Größere Merchkonflikte ist das einzige
Wo ich mir das richtig noch gefallen lasse
Wobei man selbst ganz ohne Div Editor
Ganz gut merchen kann
Man muss halt nach Dings hier suchen in der Textdatei.
Aber das verstehe ich schon.
Wenn es größere Merges sind, größere Probleme mit Merges da immer gibt,
dann würde ich sagen, ja, kann man machen.
Deswegen bin ich ja auch immer ein Fan von, wenn die Leute, also die Feature-Ersteller,
wenn die rebasen auf den aktuellen Masterstand, bevor sie ihr Merge-Request aufmachen.
Also ich hab das früher immer so gemacht.
Ich hab's ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt.
Beim alten Arbeitgeber war ja gefühlt 60% meines Tages Merch-Requests lesen.
Äh, nicht Merch-Requests.
Ja doch, Merch-Requests lesen, Dinger merchen und Release-Bau und alles mögliche in der Richtung.
Und ich hab das immer so gemacht.
ich hab den Leuten erstens gesagt,
rebase das Ding, bevor ihr ein Merch-Request
drauf macht. Wenn es
dann ein Merch-Request gab und es
trotzdem einen Merch-Konflikt gegeben hat, vielleicht
weil es mittlerweile schon andere Sachen in Master reingekommen
sind, dann hab ich versucht nochmal zu
rebasen und wenn das nicht geklappt hat,
hab ich denjenigen angerufen und hab gesagt, ey,
komm mal rüber oder lass uns mal in Teams gucken.
Wie muss das denn sein? Weil die
Feature-Ersteller wissen das natürlich besser als
man selbst.
Und das hat eigentlich immer ganz gut geklappt.
Ey, weh der noch?
Also, Fast Forward, Moment, Moment.
Fast Forward kannst du eh nur machen, wenn sich dem einen Pranschnicks geändert hat.
Das macht ja dein Git automatisch.
Es sei denn, du gibst bei dem Merch an NoFF.
Was ich in der Regel auch immer gemacht habe,
weil ich wollte explizit sehen wenn ein feature branch gemerkt wurde
Wann das war also ich habe wenn ich sagen den master gemerkt habe ich immer immer gemerkt mit no ff also kein fast vorwärts
aber gesquatscht habe ich auch nichts
ich habe den leuten gesagt
hier ihr könnt entwickeln und feature branches wie lustig seid
aber wenn ihr fertig seid macht da doch sinnvolle comments draus
und das hat in der Regel ganz gut funktioniert.
Nicht bei allen, ja, aber in der Regel hat es ganz gut
funktioniert. Die Leute haben, wenn sie fertig
waren, den Kram nochmal
resettet, haben erstmal
Rebase, haben nochmal resettet und haben ein ordentliches
Commit draus gemacht.
Wenn man das geübt hat,
dann klappt das auch.
Weil ansonsten hast du halt
in so einem Feature-Branche ganz viele
Comments,
Git-Commit-Messages
Temp1 oder
Fix oder
Blub oder was auch immer
die Leute da so reinschreiben zum Ausprobieren.
Oder hast fünfmal das
gleiche, keine Ahnung,
Fix, Blub und das steht
dann da hundertmal hintereinander drin.
Deswegen ist es ganz sinnvoll, wenn die Leute
dann einfach resetten und nochmal ein ordentliches Comment machen.
Das Schöne an Git ist, es gibt
viele Möglichkeiten und Workflows,
wie man es machen kann. Es gibt keinen, der richtig
oder falsch ist.
Nee.
Nee, nee.
Weder beim aktuellen
Arbeitgeber noch beim letzten
haben wir Git-Comets signiert.
Ja, habe ich schon gesehen, habe ich mich aber nicht
mit großartig beschäftigt.
Also ich halte nix über
GUIs Git-Geschichten
zu machen. Wir hatten einen
Entwickler, der hat
Eclipse verwendet.
Und da heißt es eGit.
Das Git-Plugin. Das heißt wirklich so.
eGit.
Und der hat teilweise
leere Comments produziert
und so was. Und er wusste nie warum.
Es ist ja auch schon
ein paar Jahre her.
Aber damals gab es auch schon
IntelliJ. Keine Ahnung, warum der Eclipse
verwendet hat.
Wahrscheinlich Boomer-Entwickler noch.
Jetzt gab es doch früher noch
NetBeans. Benutzt das überhaupt noch
irgendjemand? Ne, oder? Das ist das
komplett outdated, overrated, cheapated.
Tatsächlich, fuck, da gibt's
immer wieder neue Sachen.
NetBeans, Alter.
Guckt euch das an.
Omega-Lul.
Werbung. Gut, Leute.
Dann machen wir jetzt mal eine Runde Sellout
für zwei Minuten.
Ihr habt euch doch sicherlich schon gefragt,
wo man aktuell günstig
Storage und Nasses kaufen kann, oder?
Das habt ihr euch wahrscheinlich seit Wochen
überlegt und wartet nur darauf, euch ein neues Nass zu
kaufen. Da kann ich euch sagen, dem können
wir jetzt Abhilfe schaffen. Und zwar
ihr könnt mal bei mir auf den
Channel gucken. Da gibt es einen Rev-Link zu einem
Alternate-Store. Alternativ
könnt ihr auch, Ausrufezeichen
Ukraine, Ausrufezeichen Seagate,
Ausrufezeichen Alternate im Chat machen, dann
kriegt ihr den Link aus. Das heißt, ihr müsst gar nicht wirklich hier
in das Profil.
Da kommt ihr hier bei mir auf einem Custom Alternate
Shop raus. Da gibt es einmal
sehr günstig Festplatten
und sehr günstig
Bundles Ukraine Nasses
mit Festplatten zusammen.
Mein persönlicher Favorit ist
ja das Ding hier, beziehungsweise
das Ding hier.
Das Ukraine DXP 2800.
Einsteiger 2Bainers hat aber, wenn ich das richtig bei Ugreen gesehen habe, das hier stimmt nicht, 2,5 Gigabit Netzwerk.
Wir können doch mal gucken, dass ich jetzt keinen Mist erzähle.
Aber hier, guck hier, 2,5 Gigabyte Netzwerk.
Ihr bekommt schon 8 Gigabyte RAM.
und die CPU hat, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe, sowohl Crypto-Extensions,
das heißt, wenn ihr Sachen verschlüsseln wollt bei euch auf der Festplatte
und trotzdem 2,5 Gig erreichen wollt, dann ist das, denke ich mal, möglich.
Crypto-Extensions und ich glaube sogar, da gucken wir jetzt mal nach, QuickSync.
Das ist ein Internet... Gucken wir mal, ob der QuickSync hat, weil wenn der QuickSync hat,
dann könnt ihr damit sogar halbwegs sinnvoll, ja hat sogar QuickSync, könnt ihr damit sogar halbwegs sinnvoll CPU sparen, Videos transcoden.
Also eigentlich ein super Einstiegsnass.
Und die Preise, wohlgemerkt, gelten nur über meinen Alternate-Link.
Den Link findet ihr im Chat oder aber über meinen Kanal.
Und das Kaufen an sich ist halt auch super easy.
Hier einfach anklicken, zack, in Warenkorb, zack, direkt PayPal Checkout, let's go.
Direkt PayPal Checkout.
Und zack, dann ist es da.
Excellent.
Gut, Chat.
Sekunde, ich muss mir das kurz notieren.
Eine Stunde
58.
Eine Stunde 58.
50.
Aufwachen, Stream.
Am 28.
6.
Ja, weil die wollen garantiert
irgendwelche Reports haben mit, wo ich ordentlich
Sellout gemacht habe.
So, also lass mal weitergucken.
Was trendet noch auf GitHub diese Woche?
Arcane
hatten wir uns gerade angeschaut. Dapper.
Portable Runtime
for Building Distributed Applications
Cloud and Edge.
Ist das nicht eigentlich
so eine Datenbank-Geschichte
unter .NET?
Die heißt glaube ich Dapper ausgeschrieben.
Und das heißt DAP.
AI Agents.
Local AI.
Seaweed FS.
Das benutzen viele jetzt, weil, wie hieß das Ding?
MinIO hier eingestellt wurde.
Da benutzen das hier jetzt einige Leute als Local S3 Storage.
Ladder.
Self-Hosted Alternative to 12-Feet IO1...
Was?
Was soll das sein?
Ladder?
Schieder Chinesen?
developer tool for testing and analyzing paywall implementations
und content delivery behavior und modernes plan what entfernt paywalls von artikeln
und wie macht das wenn eine paywall bedeutet der content wird gar nicht ausgeliefert wie
Wie soll das dann funktionieren?
Oder entfernen die nur Paywalls,
wo der Content ausgeliefert wird,
aber dann per JavaScript eine Paywall vorgeschaltet wird?
Nur zum Testen, natürlich.
Genauso wie wir alle nur Linux-Distributionen runterladen.
Aber jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Ich habe mir per torrent glaube ich die letzten zehn jahre nichts mehr runtergeladen weder linux distribution noch irgendwas anderes
User agent ändern max warum hast du dich noch nicht zum bahn software update geäußert
Ich habe mir das gar nicht so genau angeguckt ehrlich gesagt
Ich habe nur mitgekriegt dass die bahn probleme hatte mit mit ihrem funk
und das ist wohl nur ein, dass das nicht
ausfallsicher gebaut war, dass die
quasi nur ein Live-System hatten
und das irgendein Software-Update
dafür gesorgt hat, dass es nicht mehr ging
und dann stand alles nachts
was genau da der Fall war, weiß
ich nicht
Gibt einen guten Deal.
Hast du was bestellt?
Excellent.
Also ich bekomme ja, muss ich ja zusagen, ne, Leute.
Ich bekomme direkt von den Sales nix.
Ich bekomme ne...
Pauschal...
Gebühr für...
Den Sellout hier im Stream.
Über nen Monat lang.
Der...
Sponsor...
Sponsor-Streams gehen noch, glaube ich, bis 8.7.
Core-Switch-Bahn nennt Ursache für bundesweiten Ausfall.
Okay.
Oh, Chat, wisst ihr, was mir aufgefallen ist?
Heute kam noch gar kein KDE-Keyring.
Bahn nennt Ursache für bundesweiten Ausfall.
Ein Softwarefehler nach dem Tausch eines Switches war die Ursache für den Ausfall des Bahnfunks.
ja das habe ich mitgekriegt der tausch des switches sei teil von planmäßigen
instandhaltungsarbeiten gewesen ein bahnbetrieb ohne zungenflug nicht möglich
ok und was ist jetzt genau passiert
bei dem getauschten gerät handelt es sich deshalb mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit um
um einen Core-Switch des IP MPLS Backbones
oder um ein Data Center Leaf Spine...
What the fuck?
...in einem zentralen Master-Rechenzentrum der Bahn.
Aha.
Also wenn es keine Fehlermeldung nach sich zog,
ist das Monitoring kacke.
Lauter Darstellung...
Also, ne?
Wenn sowas ausfällt, das merkt keiner.
Lauter Darstellung der Bahn trat nach dem Austausch
ein singulärer Softwarefehler auf.
Da hat sich auch wieder irgendeiner
aus den Fingern gesaugt als Wort.
Nach den Regeln
der Bahn für dieses Muster beschäftigt er erst
einen Cyberangriff ausschließen, bevor...
Hä?
Moment.
Die Logik verstehe ich nicht.
Ein switch geht nicht mehr und sie dürfen nicht in den backup switch einschalten weil sie erst gucken müssen dass es keine hacker attacke ist
Ja aber so oder so also wenn der switch kaputt ist oder nicht mehr geht weshalb auch immer kann man doch das andere system
Einschalten das verstehe ich nicht
Aber ganz im Ernst, Leute, ich sag euch jetzt mal, wie es ist.
Man kann ja viel über die Bahn flamen, aber das ist ein Ding, wo ich sage,
das kann passieren.
Sicherlich könnt ihr sagen, ey, warum wird das nicht richtig überwacht?
Warum ist nicht automatischer Ausfall?
So Dinge, wenn das mal passieren würde, wäre das kein Problem.
Guck mal, das ist jetzt in zig Jahren einmal passiert, kein Ding.
Also das ist so was, was ich durchaus der Bahn verzeihen würde.
Was ich der Bahn halt nicht verzeihen kann.
und warum ich eigentlich auf nichts auf der Welt irgendwie richtigen, tiefen, abgrundtiefen Hass verspüre,
außer auf die Bahn, ist der Rest, den die Bahn so treibt.
Ich will mich jetzt gar nicht drüber auslassen, weil sonst rege ich mich wieder auf.
Aber das ist ein Fehler, das kann passieren.
Wir haben alle schon Ausfälle erlebt, die vermeidbar gewesen wären.
Vielleicht stellen sie es dramatisch,
um einen Fehler kleinzureden.
Ja, das kann sein.
Kubernetes trendet.
Kubernetes.
Oder wie es einer bei mir auf der alten Arbeit
immer ausgesprochen hat, Kybernetis.
Ich finde ja Kybernetis am besten.
Oder in irgendeinem Marketing-Typ
Hatte doch letztens mal
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das auf der Arbeit war
Oder ob wir das im Stream geguckt haben
Der hat gesagt
Kybernetische Umgebung
Das war ganz abgedreht, Alter
In kybernetischen Umgebung
Da habe ich mich dann so gefragt
Moment
Weiß der, wovon er redet?
Gitti Trended.
Wahrscheinlich würde ich mir
Forge.io mittlerweile installieren, wenn ich
nochmal neu mein lokales
Git-Webinterface aufsetzen würde.
Syncthing, das gibt es auch schon
ewig.
Ethereum Improvement
Proposal Repository. Oh, das könnte vielleicht
auf der Arbeit relevant.
Wir haben ja da Ethereum-Nodes.
Docker Compose.
Ich dachte, Docker Compose
ist mittlerweile Build-In bei Docker.
Aber anscheinend doch noch als eigenes Repo.
Weil es gibt ja Docker Compose
und Docker Minus Compose.
Go Music DL
China Chinesen App
Ah ja, music.zkkp.nyc
MN, what? Ich weiß gar nicht was das für ein Land überhaupt ist. Was ist denn MN für ein Land?
ATLD nicht TDL
Mongolei.
Alter.
Ich glaube, das ist das erste Mal, dass ich eine Domain gesehen habe, die der Mongolei gehört.
Genghis Khan Music oder irgendwie sowas.
Ne, ne, die Seite traue ich mich nicht aufzumachen
Wer weiß, wo man da rauskommt
Also, ein Monk
In Rust, natürlich
Written in Rust, oder in Go
Ja, wie jetzt?
Warum gibt es das in Rust und Go?
FPS-Tld, ja
Das wäre auch nicht schlecht
Okay, Helm trendet
Ich muss ja ehrlich sagen, Helm ist so ein Ding.
Also ich meine, ich finde das ganz praktisch, dass es das gibt.
Aber ich habe immer den Eindruck, wenn ich mir diese Go-Template-Sachen da angucken muss und einsch...
Ich habe irgendwie den Eindruck, Helm hat sich nur durchgesetzt, weil es eines der ersten Sachen in der Richtung war.
Also, das wirkt an vielen Stellen, finde ich, nicht richtig durchdacht.
Außerdem mag ich diese Go-Template-Syntax nicht.
Ja, und manche Sachen kannst du von einem anderen Teil des Charts inkluden, manche wieder nicht.
Es ist wir.
Psyllium Go Micro.
Harness. Okay, AI.
Dann machen wir heute mal ausnahmsweise,
gucken wir mal, was bei den Krustentieren
so trendet.
Da gab's doch
von FireShip letztens ein Video,
was
angeblich ab 18
war und wir nicht gucken konnten.
Mal gucken, ob das Video jetzt nicht mal ab 18 ist.
Aha, Leute, das Video scheint nicht mal ab 18 zu sein.
Das können wir uns gleich angucken.
Das können wir uns gleich angucken, was Fireship zu Tour so sagt.
Okay, auf welcher Basis?
bestimmt tauchi das ist doch auch eine ki
ist auf tauchi basis ja ist das dachte ich mir
mir.
Game Engine Build
in Rust. Weiß nicht, ob da wirklich irgendjemand Games
damit entwickelt. Rust Desk?
Das benutzen die indischen Scammer
mittlerweile sogar auch schon.
Das hatten wir schon mal.
Hab ich nicht gecheckt.
Hör,
da hab ich letztens irgendein Video
gesehen zu
Agent Multiplexing, bla,
blub, T-Mux
für KI quasi.
Das hatten wir auch schon mal.
AI.
Ne.
Text to Speech.
Hyper.
Gibt es auch schon ewig.
HTTP stellt es für Rust.
Minecraft.
Influx.
Moment.
Chat.
Seit wann ist InfluxDB in Rust schon immer?
Ne, oder?
InfluxDB war doch nicht schon immer in Rust.
Moment, das müssen wir jetzt mal kurz kontrollieren.
InfluxDB V0.05, das ist es.
Source.
In Go war das damals.
Ne?
Genau.
Seit wann kann das sein, dass sie von der KI auch das rewriten lassen in Rust?
Ob das so eine gute Idee ist?
Aber es ist schon eine Weile
Aber es ist schon eine Weile so
Ja, ist schon eine Weile
Guck mal, das ist schon eine ganze Weile hier
Wahrscheinlich seit der 3er
Vielleicht haben die seit der 3er rewritten
Ja, okay, wahrscheinlich die 3er
Und die 2er wird dann wahrscheinlich noch
noch Go gewesen sein, ha?
Nee, auch nicht.
Okay, das...
Das, äh...
Das ist letzter Monat?
Was ist denn die letzte Version in Go?
Zwei? Zwei war auch
schon in Rust.
Guck mal, das war auch schon in Rust vor sechs
Jahren. Die können das...
Da gab's noch keine KI.
Die haben das von Hunt Rewrite
zum größten Teil, ha?
Interessant, wusste ich gar nicht, dass es in Go ist
Bett
Das ist ganz witzig
Das ist quasi Cat
Nur mit Syntax Highlighting und sowas
Das rechts geht nicht auf den Tag
Achso
InfluxDB
Okay, vor zwei Jahren
Aber InfluxDB hat eh ziemlich an Bedeutung verloren
Die letzten Jahre über
Ja, BAT ist auch so ein Programm
An sich ganz cool
Aber weiterer Grund
Also, ähnlicher Grund, warum ich es nicht benutze, wie bei allen anderen dieser Tools.
Ich will mich nicht an irgendwelche extra Tools gewöhnen, wenn ich doch auf Linux-Servern den ganzen Tag nur die Standard-Tools zur Verfügung habe.
An sich ist BAT eine coole Sache.
Es ist im Prinzip CAT mit Syntax-Highlighting.
Was nutzt du für einen Browser?
Ich benutze Firefox, also unter Linux. Unter Linux benutze ich Firefox und Chromium.
Unter Windows benutze ich Chrome, Chromium und Firefox.
Hyper Switch
Okay, das ist mir zu böse sein. Tapas Ribgrab?
Windmill?
Moment, das muss ich jetzt mal durchlesen.
Was?
Open Source Developer Platform
to power your entire infra and turn
scripts into webhooks, workflows and UIs.
Faster Workflow Engine, Open Source. Alter.
Was? Was?
Das check ich nicht. Okay, KI.
Was? Was? Wie?
Was soll das sein?
Chat, ich hab das jetzt gelesen und
checke nicht, um was es geht.
Dreimal mehr Airflow?
What?
Ach, 13 mal schneller als Airflow?
Was zum Teufel bin ich hier sehend?
Windmill.dev
Workflow Engine
Code First Orchestration Platform for Internal Software
Kann ich mir jetzt genauso wenig darunter vorstellen.
Das ist doch eine Art Workflow Engine?
Okay, irgendein...
Okay, keine Ahnung. Irgendwes das Enterprise-Ding,
was ich garantiert daheim nicht brauchen werde.
So.
Dann gucken wir doch jetzt als letztes Mal,
was trendet denn so in der C-Sharp?
Oh ne, wir gucken mal was anderes.
Was trendet denn, das wollte ich mal nachgucken,
Was kennen wir denn in Bash oder in Shell?
Was für Repos haben wir?
Was für Bash-Repos?
Skills.
Windows.
N8n-Skills.
Thermux-Packages.
Dream-Server.
Skills.
Docker-Android.
Agmsg.
Gentoo.
Nicht so spannend.
So, was trennt er denn in der .NET Welt?
Letztes, was wir uns davon angucken.
So, PowerShell, natürlich.
PowerShell for every system.
Ja, man glaubt es kaum.
Es gibt Leute, die benutzen wirklich PowerShell unter Linux.
Man kann sich das nicht vorstellen, aber es gibt es.
Ich verstehe es nicht so ganz, aber okay.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich sag's ja immer wieder, wenn man jetzt mal für Windows spricht, ne
Ich finde, PowerShell ist an sich eine richtig gute Automatisierungsplattform
Es ist aber eine schlechte, wie ich finde
Basiert jetzt nicht auf so wahnsinnig viel Erfahrung, aber das, was ich bisher so mitgekriegt hab
Als ich ein paar Mal da versucht hab, was mitzumachen
Ich finde, als interaktive Shell ist PowerShell nicht so geil
also hier interaktive shell täglich hier so verwenden sachen auf der kommando zahlmann
dafür nicht power schon nicht so geil um sachen zu automatisieren weil du halt viele fertige cmd
letzte glaube ich bei windows hast um mit windows intern sachen zu interagieren ist power schon
richtig gut
er gutes trifft ehrlich so ganz wie es
eigentlich eine eigene vor allem
pauschale sind und programm einfach
stehe was du meinst mit mit mit wsl hast
du quasi eine ordentliche shell unter
Windows, eine Unix-artige
Shell unter Windows und damit hast du eine Windows-Shell
unter Linux. Aber es gibt Leute, die das
verwenden. Ich weiß unter Linux, ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau warum, aber es gibt das.
EF Core,
Datenbankstells,
Blazer, geh mir bloß fort,
Alter. Blazer mach ich einen riesen...
Ihr wisst, dass ich .NET bzw. C-Sharp-Fan bin,
aber Blazer mach ich einen großen
Bogen drum. Avalonia ist wahrscheinlich
die einzig sinnvolle Cross-Plattform-
GUI-Geschichte in .NET, aber
allein schon, wenn ich hier an XAML
denke, kriege ich Anfälle. Wobei es
ja wohl irgendwie jetzt möglich ist,
Avalonia-UIs
halbwegs gescheit, ganz ohne XAML
zu machen, habe ich bei denen auf der Seite mal gelesen.
Everything Toolbar.
Das ist irgendwie so ein Suchprogramm, ne?
Ja.
Also eine gescheite
Suche für die Taskbar,
die nicht
sagt, wie die von Microsoft.
Microsoft hat zu viel gevibe-coded.
Was hältst du von Swift?
Ich habe mit Swift noch nie was gemacht
Ich habe nur ein paar Videos zu gesehen
Und mir ein paar Code Beispiele angeguckt
Und ich finde Swift
Sieht ein bisschen
Sieht eigentlich auch nach einer ganz
Swift Examen
Sieht eigentlich nach einer ganz guten Mischung aus
Aus
Bisschen
Es hat ein bisschen was
Java Artig
Also ganz kleines bisschen was.
Ja, was hier scharpartiges.
Mit ein bisschen funktionaler Geschichte.
Ähm.
Ja, gibt's da nicht.
Small example.
Okay, da fragen wir die KI.
Das sah eigentlich ganz gut aus.
Ja.
Also das hat mir von dem, was ich gesehen habe, gefallen.
Der Teufel steckt aber sowas ja immer im Detail.
Wenn man sich mehr damit beschäftigt, wird man wahrscheinlich zig Sachen finden, die einen abfacken.
PowerShell brauchst du, wenn du mit Azure interagieren willst. Warum?
Die Terraform-Azure-Provider sind top.
und außerdem hat Azure
die haben doch ihr eigenes Terraform
wie hießen das nochmal
Biceps oder so, gell
das Ding haben die doch
aber die Terraform Module
für Azure sind top, da brauchst du nicht unbedingt
PowerShell
aber das halte ich von Zwift
also ich kann nicht viel zu sagen
aber das was ich gesehen habe sah eigentlich ganz brauchbar aus
Office CLI.
So narr.
Ja, das geht bestimmt nicht.
Die Azure CLI für Linux ist bestimmt auch nicht verkehrt.
Ja, ja.
Lange nichts mehr mit Azure gemacht.
Seit ich beim neuen Arbeitgeber bin, ist es hauptsächlich Google.
Wir haben da zwar auch ein bisschen was in Azure, aber es ist 95% Google.
OSU.
Ah, ja, ja.
package manager ui sephira kde connect alternative aha das ist ganz interessant
haben wir KDE Connect verwendet.
Unity, Files.
Okay.
Ja, dann haben wir alles.
Diese Woche nicht so wirklich viel Spannendes
in den GitHub Trends dabei.
Was machst du eigentlich genau auf der Arbeit?
Ich reiße den ganzen Tag
per Terraform irgendwelche Ressourcen ab
und baue sie wieder auf.
Und ab und zu editiere ich mal ein bisschen Terraform,
weil irgendeiner der Meinung ist,
keine Ahnung, er braucht mehr RAM,
irgendwelche IP-Adressen müssen erlaubt werden,
um auf die Kubernetes-Control-Plane
hinzuzugreifen. Dann lasse ich das
laufen, lasse vielleicht noch ein paar neue
VMs aufbauen über Terraform, lasse dann
ein Ansible-Post-Shop drüber laufen,
editiere ein bisschen im Ansible rum.
Ich bin eher Jammel-Engineer
mittlerweile.
Ja.
Und ich bin oft noch auf Oldschool-
4 ms und cloud-servern eingeloggt und machte halt die üblichen dinger von
hilfe meine anwendung ist abgekackt oder wo die festplatte läuft voll wegen logs
oder guck mal ob wir da nicht was upgraden können irgendwie java file
dahin schieben also ist auch noch viel klassisch so was man eigentlich früher
so als server admin gemacht hat dabei
aber hauptsächlich kümmere ich mich tatsächlich um google cloud
infrastruktur und jammel engineer so vor mich hin habt ihr schon mal nix us-stadt
ansible in der arbeit benutzt das werden wir auch in nächster zeit garantiert
nicht sehen bei uns weil wir verwenden ansible ja auch nicht nur für linux die
verwenden ansible ja auch für windows mittlerweile keine ahnung wusste gar
nicht dass das taugt
Also ich bin Senior Linux Engineer, wobei das stimmt nicht.
Mittlerweile, mittlerweile haben die die Jobs ja umbenannt.
Ich bin jetzt Senior Site Reliability Engineer.
Keck weh, Alter.
Klingt einfach geiler und moderner.
Warum, weiß ich nicht, weil es sich besser anhört.
Und ab und zu entwickle ich ein paar kleine Tools, die wir intern gebrauchen können bei der Arbeit.
Hauptsächlich in Go, weil Go POC ist für Self-Contained Single Binaries.
Kannst du auf jede x-beliebige Linux-Kiste kopieren und ausführen und es funktioniert.
Ist denn die Site reliable?
Ich würde sagen,
also in zwei größere Projekte,
für die ich zuständig bin
in der Google Cloud.
Ich würde sagen,
das eine ist ziemlich reliable,
das andere ist etwas weniger reliable.
Das liegt aber weniger an mir.
Das liegt daran,
dass die Software so kacke ist.
Wir haben da ein Polygon,
also Polygon Blockchain Node laufen
und die Software ist so bodenlos Schrott,
ich kann euch das ich kann euch mal kurz zeigen also wenn man einen polygon not
betreiben will gibt es die offizielle software von polygon die nennt sich bohr
und es gibt es oft die nennt sich eri gon dies eigentlich deutlich nicer und
mittlerweile auch vom von polygon team entwickelt damit kann man den polygon
Node betreiben. So, das Ding ist jetzt nur,
dass Polygon gesagt hat,
Polygon?
Die hier.
Die haben gesagt, ey Erygon-Team,
wir haben keinen Bock mehr, euch Geld zu bezahlen.
Und die haben Erygon jetzt geforkt.
Und dieser Fork ist
so ziemlich die schlecht...
Ist es das überhaupt?
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wo das
richtige Repo mittlerweile ist. Alter!
Dieser Fork von denen,
ist die beschissenste Software, die ich jemals gesehen habe.
Das ist so schlimm, dass sie teilweise Software ab...
Also das hört einfach von heute auf morgen auf zu funktionieren,
weil sie an irgendwas nicht gedacht haben.
Und damit es dann wieder funktioniert,
musst du dir von irgendeinem privaten Docker-Repo,
OCI-Repo von denen,
eine nicht releaste private Version des Forks von denen ziehen,
dass dein Blockchain-Node wieder funktioniert.
Das ist wirklich komplett unterste Schublade,
was die da treiben.
Und ich gucke bei denen öfters auch
im Discord rein.
Da wird nur geflamed.
Das ist so schlimm,
dass die mittlerweile bei uns auf der Arbeit
zusätzlich noch Ethereum
angebunden haben und das verwenden wollen.
Eigentlich ist Polygon pro Transaktion
ein bisschen günstiger
als Ethereum, aber
es ist einfach deutlich angenehmer zu betreiben.
also das ist wirklich schrott
das ist schrott
also die Site ist nicht
sonderlich reliable, wegen der Software
ist der ganze Cloud-Kram wirklich notwendig
oder hätten es auch bei internen Server getan
klar, ey, du kannst so gut wie alles
was du in der Cloud betreibst, auch intern betreiben
also rein von der Technik her geht das
wenn du da genug Server-Ressourcen
Anbindung und alles hast, kannst du das auch intern betreiben
Was bei Cloud-Geschichten halt der Vorteil ist, wenn es halbwegs dynamisch sein soll.
Wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel sagst, ey, heute brauchen wir 3 VMs, morgen brauchen wir 15 VMs.
Heute haben wir einen Cluster mit 2 Nodes, morgen soll der schön hochskalieren können auf 18 Nodes oder sowas.
Dafür ist das top.
Von dieser Geschichte kommt ja auch immer diese Sache mit, auch mit Cloud kann man Geld sparen.
meiner erfahrung nach spart man mit cloud kein geld und bezahlt wahrscheinlich sogar
ein bisschen mehr aber daher kommt die idee man kann mit der cloud geld sparen also sprich man
bezahlt nur das was man wirklich braucht ob das in der praxis so ist naja also für dieses projekt
muss man ehrlich sagen wäre das nicht nötig in der cloud laufen zu lassen könnte man ohne probleme
auch im eigenen Rechenzentrum laufen lassen.
Der Vorteil für uns ist halt nur,
dass wir eine Managed Kubernetes Plattform
verwenden können.
Und Kubernetes selbst betreiben
ist halt ein bisschen abfuck.
Fängt ja schon an mit
Gateway API oder Ingress.
Du musst ja irgendwie
Traffic in deinen Cluster reinbekommen.
Wenn du Kubernetes selbst installierst,
ist da erstmal kein Ingress dabei.
So nachinstallieren.
bei google sagt er einfach hier will will gateway api verwenden und zack macht das google für dich
damals unter der haube alles schon mit bringt das schon alles mit google kümmert sich beispielsweise
auch darum dass seine kuba netz control plan legen und wie sich geupdatet wird und so was
also das ist schon ein schlechter manager zu haben du musst du musst auf jeden fall die in
einen eigenen ingress oder einen eigenen gateway api controller installieren ja ja wenn du das
verwenden willst sonst kannst du kein ingress oder gateway verwenden und so sachen wie laut balancer
ist auch nicht so einfach möglich also wenn du da wenn du eine externe ip haben willst und mit
einem laut balancer dahinter das geht auch nicht so ohne weiteres weil du brauchst halt du kannst
zwar die Ressourcen im Cluster anlegen,
aber wenn da nichts dahinter ist, was
dann wirklich den Loadbalancer anlegt mit der externen
IP, geht's nicht. Naja, du musst da ganz
viel selbst machen. Also, Kubernetes
selbst betreiben ist ziemlicher Abfuck.
Es gibt da mittlerweile Angebote von
VMware. VMware hatte eine Weile
Tanzu am Start. Mittlerweile
ist es nicht mehr Tanzu, sondern ich glaube, das heißt
jetzt irgendwie VMware Cloud
Foundation oder sowas. Ist aber letztendlich
das Gleiche. Ob man das betreiben
will, weiß ich nicht. Also, Azure
und AWS und Google
haben halt mit mit managt mit seiner manager kubernetes plattform doch schon
die vorteile dass du dich um weniger kümmern muss dass du dich dann nur noch
um den cluster selbst kümmern muss und um die anwendung die drauf laufen und
weniger viel viel weniger um das was drumherum ist ja zum beispiel wenn bei
google wenn ich sage ich brauche jetzt eine gateway oder einen ingress mit
einer externen ip dass das alles geht legst du dns einträge bei google an über
Terraform.
Und im Cluster
deployt dann irgendwie einer
ein Gateway-Objekt und zack, oder eine
HTTP-Route, müsste man ja sagen.
Und zack ist das Ganze da.
Also da ist das wirklich praktisch.
Aber man hätte das ohne Probleme
auch mit internen Servern betreiben können,
keine Frage.
Möglich ist das alles.
Also es gibt kaum was, was nur in der Cloud möglich ist.
Es ist halt immer die Frage, wie viel Arbeit und Stress man sich dadurch erspart.
Umgedreht kann man sich auch fragen, wenn man es übertreibt, wie viel Stress macht man sich damit?
Weil man muss ja auch mal ehrlich sagen, es muss nicht alles in der Cloud in einem Kubernetes-Cluster laufen.
Wenn ich jetzt eine kleine Anwendung habe, also angenommen ich entwickle eine kleine Anwendung und will da erstmal gucken, wie gut kommt das Ganze an,
da kann ich mir auch einfach
eine VM bei Headslam mieten, die Anwendung
da drauf kopieren, starten
und wenn ich Advanced bin
mache ich noch ein Reverse Proxy davor, dass ich ordentlich
SSL habe und gut ist
das ist dann eine Sache, wenn man
das selbst, das kann man ja sogar per Ansible machen, wenn man das
reproduzierbar haben will, das macht man
dann einmal und danach ist der
Server in einer Viertelstunde wieder
out of the box da
dafür quasi ein Kubernetes betreiben
und sonst was, man darf ja nicht vergessen, das ist ja
auch nicht gerade billig ja also google lässt sich das müssen gcp pricing müsst
euch das mal angucken also google lässt sich das ja auch ordentlich bezahlen
wir machen jetzt mal nur nur vm ja nur compute engine wir machen jetzt noch
kein kuba nebes cluster wir sagen jetzt einfach mal weg wir machen jetzt nur
mal eine ganz normale ganz normale computer die ist die ist 24 7 an general
Purpose.
Ach guck mal, bei N4 sind wir mittlerweile.
Nehmen wir halt mal die neuere Kiste.
N4 Standard.
Zwei VCPUs, 8 GB RAM.
Ja, bam.
67 Euro im Monat.
Also das ist nicht billig.
Bei Hetzner kostet sowas 8 Euro, glaube ich.
Google lässt sich das halt das Ökosystem bezahlen.
Google lässt sich halt wirklich das Ökosystem drum herum bezahlen.
Ne, aber die Preise sind immer noch deutlich günstiger.
Guck hier.
8 GB, 2 cores.
Guck mal, hier bezahlst du 16 Euro im Monat für 16 GB und 8 cores.
Wenn ihr das...
8 Cores,
16 Gig,
235 Euro.
Also ganz ehrlich, Preise für 4Ms und solche Sachen sind brutal.
Also bei Azure ist das auch nicht viel besser.
Bei AWS wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Das ist teuer als fuck.
Die lassen sich das Ökosystem halt bezahlen.
So, und jetzt gehen wir mal sogar hier hin und sagen...
Ich benutze diesen komischen Rechner hier nicht oft, weil...
Ich muss es ja nicht bezahlen.
Keck, wait.
Ähm...
Äh...
Kubernetes?
Da geht's schon los, ne?
Da geht's schon los.
Wie viele Nodes sind da standardmäßig?
Kann man gar nicht einstellen.
Nur den Machine Type.
Aber hier irgendwie...
Ach, hier landen wir auf Nodes.
Doch, 5.
Okay, sagen wir mal 3.
Aber das...
Okay, und sagen wir mal...
Okay, komm.
8 Kerne.
Und 16.
16 Giga-Gramm.
Sagen wir mal ein bisschen...
Aber trotzdem.
Die lassen sich den Komfort wirklich bezahlen, ne?
Also, ein 3-Node-Kubernetes-Cluster.
Mit...
16.
Hallo.
Ich hab 16 ein paar mal getippt.
Das lassen die sich halt wirklich ordentlich bezahlen.
Also die belassen sich das Ökosystem bezahlen
und die lassen sich halt auch den Komfort bezahlen.
Das muss man da halt sehen.
Das ist teuer.
Das ist wirklich nicht ohne.
ja und in den projekten haben wir zwei größere kubaniertes cluster wir haben allerdings muss
sagen pro projekt gibt es natürlich vier umgebung es gibt eine entwicklungsumgebung
der test umgebung integrations umgebung und produktionsumgebung das heißt wir haben acht
mit Cluster.
In den zwei Projekten.
Wir sind allerdings
mittlerweile so weit,
dass wir auch
die Integrationsumgebung
kleiner skalieren dürfen als Produktion.
Das ist halt der Witz,
wenn du aus der reinen On-Prem-Welt
kommst, also historisch
gesehen, und jetzt in der
Cloud unterwegs bist, da gibt es halt so Dinge,
irgendjemand hat mal eine Vorgabe
geschrieben die produktions umgebung muss exakt genauso aussehen wie die testung
beziehungsweise wie die integrations umgebung hat man irgendjemand irgendwo
hingeschrieben und dementsprechend wenn du jetzt für deinen produktiven
kubernetes cluster 10 10 note cluster hast hätten wenn du streng genommen
eins zu eins so auslegst hättest du integration auch einen 10 note cluster
gebraucht obwohl dort nichts läuft einfach nur damit es gleich ist
mittlerweile sind sie mittlerweile sind sie schon auf den trichter gekommen es
reicht wenn der cluster gleich konfiguriert ist aber der sich runter
skaliert weil du eben nur drei nodes in integration brauchst wenn auch wenn du
zehn aus den produktionen brauchst ja ganz am anfang haben wir noch gesagt
integration muss auch zehn node cluster sein auch wenn es in produktion zehn node
cluster ist muss das immer gleich sein macht halt keinen sinn
also muss halt auch alte alte sachen anpassen wenn du in der cloud unterwegs
bist und kannst nicht alles eins zu eins zu übertragen aber ihr seht der scheiß
ist teuer das ist wirklich nicht ohne
aktuell kümmere ich mich weil es darum ging weil ich auf der arbeit macht ich
bin aktuell zuständig für lasst mich mal kurz überlegen
Zwei Cloud-Services.
Und, ich kann jetzt die Namen nicht sagen, lass mich mal kurz zählen.
Vier.
Vier Oldschool.
Zwei Cloud-Services.
Und vier alte, äh, ja.
im RZ
Services.
Bin ich aktuell für zuständig.
Die größten davon sind aber
tatsächlich die hier.
Ja, also sprich,
in der Cloud betreiben wir
also, das sind
2x4 Umgebungen
mit jeweils einem Kubernetes Cluster drin
und einigen, sagen wir mal, Support
4Ms drumherum.
Ne, ich hab
gar kein Battlefield 6 bisher gespielt.
Die On-Prem-Services, die ich habe, die bestehen auch jeweils aus vier Umgebungen, aber der eine Service hat nur einen Server pro Umgebung.
Das hält sich in Grenzen. Das sind quasi vier Umgebungen mit jeweils einem Server. Das hält sich in Grenzen.
Die anderen sind ein bisschen umfangreicher, aber das hält sich in Grenzen.
Also die größten Sachen, um die ich mich kümmere, sind tatsächlich die zwei Cloud-Services.
und da bin ich eigentlich den ganzen tag beschäftigt mit irgendwelche dinge ändern
konfigurieren ausprobieren ja lass mal überlegen was habe ich am freitag gemacht zum beispiel habe
ich mich am freitag habe ich wieder richtig viel jammel engineer ich erzähle jetzt einfach mal
ein bisschen ausführlicher weil jemand gefragt hat was ich auf der arbeit zu machen am freitag
habe ich wieder hardcore jammel engineer so also folgendes problem kubernetes selbst sagt okay ich
versuche das mal so zu erklären, auch für Leute, die nicht so
viel damit machen.
Also, stellt euch vor, ihr habt einen Service
in Kubernetes laufen. Kubernetes
könnt ihr euch vorstellen wie
ein Docker-Cluster, okay?
Ein Cluster aus vielen Docker-Containern.
Docker-Cluster
ist Kubernetes. Da macht
er halt ein bisschen Magic drumherum. Also,
ein geklustertes Docker
ist das im Endeffekt. So, jetzt habt ihr
Container laufen. Jetzt müsst ihr
ja irgendwie von außen
auf die Container zugreifen können.
Ist letztendlich wie bei Docker, wenn ihr Docker-Container laufen lasst, müsst ihr auch Ports weiterleiten.
Bei Docker an sich ist das Ganze noch relativ easy, weil in der Regel läuft der Container auf einem Host und ihr könnt einfach den Port weiterleiten und ihr gebt dann an, Host-IP Doppelpunkt 123456 oder so.
Äh, ne. 12345. Dann landet ihr auf dem Service.
Bei Kubernetes ist das ein bisschen anders, weil da können die Container ja permanent über den ganzen Cluster verteilt laufen.
Also es können Teile, sagen wir eure Anwendung, die ihr dadurch betreibt, besteht aus fünf verschiedenen Containern.
Weil man sagen muss, genau genommen nennt sich das Pots in Kubernetes, die kleinste Einheit in Kubernetes Managed ist ein Pot.
Pots können aus mehreren Containern bestehen.
Aber nennen wir das mal Container.
Ja, es könnte ja auch sein, dass die Anwendung verteilt ist.
Ja, einer läuft auf dem Node, einer auf dem Node, einer auf dem Node und drunter.
Aber es gibt irgendein Frontend von der Anwendung.
Ja, ein Container hat ein Webfrontend.
und das müsst ihr jetzt irgendwie erreichen.
Ihr wisst ja aber nicht, auf welchem...
Silium ist, glaube ich, mittlerweile überall unter der Haube.
Aber wir haben Istio am Starten, die benutzen, glaube ich, Silium.
So, und irgendwo auf irgendwie einem der Cluster-Nodes
läuft jetzt eure Anwendung auf Port 12345,
aber ihr wisst ja nicht, auf welcher IP,
weil die könnt ihr auch morgen schon wieder auf einem anderen Cluster-Node laufen.
So, dafür braucht man sowas wie einen Ingress- bzw. Gateway-AP.
Das ist quasi der Eingang in den Kubernetes Cluster. Unter der Haube, bleiben wir mal bei Ingress, unter der Haube ist das ein Nginx, der selbst wiederum als Container im Kubernetes Cluster läuft.
und der wird dann so konfiguriert, dass er eben die Sachen weiterleitet an die Container.
Dazu braucht man aber Unterstützung vom jeweiligen Cloud-Anbieter,
weil das Ding braucht ja, wenn es angesprochen werden soll,
eine externe IP oder irgendeine IP, die erreichbar ist von außen.
Ja, dazu brauchst du Support vom Cloud-Anbieter,
dass dein Ingress auch eine externe IP kriegt, wo du darauf zugreifen kannst.
Deswegen Ingress alleine bringt dir nichts,
der Cloud-Anbieter muss dir da ein bisschen Arbeit abnehmen.
Wenn du selbst ein Kubernetes-Cluster betreiben würdest,
müsstest du dich selbst komplett drum kümmern.
So, dann hast du den Ingress mit der Public IP auf Port 80
und intern wird das weitergeleitet auf deine Container auf Port 12345.
Dann ist deine Anwendung erreichbar.
So, jetzt ist es so, Ingress, ihr seht es schon hier,
Ingress ist das alte.
Aktuell bei Kubernetes ist Gateway-AP.
Gateway-AP ist quasi das neue Ingress.
Ist ein bisschen aufgesplitterter.
Das, was früher Ingress-Objekte waren, sind jetzt HTTP-Routen.
Und dann gibt es noch Gateway-Classes und die eigentlichen Gateway mit Listener und sonst was.
Müssen wir jetzt nicht weiter ausbreiten.
Zumindest unsere Anwendung, die wir laufen lassen, die wir eingekauft haben von einem Hersteller,
die Anwendung unterstützt nur Ingress.
Aber Kubernetes sagt, Ingress ist eigentlich deprecated oder wird nicht mal weiterentwickelt.
Wir sollen Gateway-AP verwenden.
Das ist halt ein bisschen doof.
aber der Hersteller der Anwendung sagt, wir unterstützen
nur Ingress
jetzt wollen wir natürlich Ingress loswerden
beziehungsweise müssen
Ingress auch über kurz oder lang
loswerden
weil Ingress nicht mehr supported werden soll
bei uns
es gibt doch auch andere Ingresses, ja ja
gibt es, gibt es, aber generell ist die
Marschrichtung vom Kubernetes Projekt klar
es soll Richtung
das ist ja auch noch geil, dass es
Ingress Nginx und Nginx Ingress gibt
die Marschrichtung ist klar, es soll Richtung
Gateway API gehen
es gibt, um die Verwirrung noch komplett zu machen
es gibt Ingress Engine X und Engine X Ingress
Ingress Engine X ist glaube ich
der Ingress offiziell vom
Kubernetes Projekt auf Basis von Engine X
und Engine X Ingress
ist vom Engine X Projekt
ein Kubernetes Ingress auf Engine X Basis
MonkaS, Alter
also die Marschrichtung ist klar
es soll Richtung Gateway API gehen
jetzt haben wir uns überlegt, was können
wir machen der hersteller sagt sie supporten nur ingress also benutzen wir doch einfach nicht den
ingress engine x sondern wir benutzen einfach den gk ingress es gibt ja auch direkt von google einen
ingress provider für kubernetes cluster könnte auch traffic installieren oder sonstwas aber
wir haben gesagt ey wir benutzen wir probieren das mal mit dem offiziellen ingress von google
Hat auch ganz gut funktioniert.
Dann sind allerdings unsere Verantwortlichen für die Anwendung auf eine, man könnte sagen, geniale Idee gekommen.
Und zwar Helm PostRenderer Script.
Die Anwendung wird per Helm installiert.
Helm ist letztendlich eine Template Engine für YAML Files.
Ja, so. Und die haben jetzt einen Post-Renderer für Helm erstellt, der alle Ingress-Ressourcen konvertiert in Gateway- bzw. in HTTP-Routen für Gateway-AP.
Im Prinzip sagt der Hersteller der Anwendung weiterhin, sie unterstützen bloß Ingress.
Allerdings haben unsere Anwendungsverantwortlichen jetzt einen Post-Renderer laufen, der das, was dieses offizielle Helm-Chart ausspuckt von dem Hersteller, umwandelt.
In http-routen die mit gateway api funktionieren
Also das das das hört sich ein bisschen hacky an ist es auch
Und ich war jetzt den ganzen freitag damit beschäftigt wie ich
Unsere gateway unsere und zum gateway listen an beibringen kann
dass sie auf port 443
ein zertifikat benutzen was mehrere
Namen erlaubt.
Wir haben zum Beispiel, wir brauchen
Sternchen.gateway.blub.de
zum Beispiel.
Brauchen wir in unserem Zertifikat.
Wir brauchen auch dann
gateway.blub.de
und wir brauchen noch
kekw.de
Diese drei Sachen brauchen wir
in unserem Zertifikat, was ausgeliefert werden muss
von unserem Gateway-API.
Und da habe ich Freitag wirklich
ewig dran rumgebastelt, bis das
funktioniert hat, dass
die Gateway-AP, der Listener
auf Port 443, ein Zertifikat
ausliefert, was gültig
ist
für alle unsere Domains.
Ja,
Cert Manager, mit Cert Manager machen wir das.
Ich musste im Endeffekt
eine Zertifikats-Ressource anlegen,
die das enthält und
einen zusätzlichen Listener an unseren Gateway
dran pappen,
auf Port 443. Das Problem war
nur und jetzt kommen wir wieder zu dirty hacks das problem war nur dass unser kuban das das
manager kuba net ist was wir da haben bzw das terraform modul mit dem wir das installieren
standardmäßig wenn du gateway ap installiert standardmäßig immer ein gateway anlegen will
soll ich auch auf 443 und jetzt musste ich irgendwie da drum rum basteln dass wir den
standard gateway weiterhin haben der aber nicht greift und unser geld wäre
auf beides auf port 4 3 und aber für unsere anwendung diese sachen hier
greifen jetzt habe ich super krassen dort die heck reingebaut der offizielle
also der geld wäre damit geliefert wird von diesem terraform installer für den
kuba netz cluster der registriert jetzt ein gateway unter zzz dort die heck punkt
blub.de
Und nachdem das ZZZZ
im Namen hat, ist das von den Regeln
her immer das allerletzte, was greift
und immer unser Zertifikat
kommt zuerst.
Ich hoffe, man hat jetzt halbwegs verstanden, was Sache ist.
Alter, bis ich auf die Idee gekommen bin,
das hat eine ganze Weile gedauert, ja?
Also wer meint, in der Cloud
läuft das alles viel ordentlicher und
vielmehr nach Best Practices
DevOps-mäßig,
der hat sich getäuscht.
Es ist dort genauso viel
gefrickelt und gebastelt, wie alles andere.
Auch der einzige Vorteil,
den man da hat, ist allerdings
im Vergleich zu von Hand gefrickelt,
dass es in irgendwelchen YAML-Files
drin steht oder in irgendwelchen
Terraform-Files und es nachvollziehbar
ist und in gewissem
Rahmen auch reproduzierbar
ist.
Damit so viel zu dem was ich auf die arbeit macht also ich habe am freitag hardcore jammel engine wird wieder
Ich glaube nicht dass uns nix os in irgendeiner art und weise dabei geholfen hätte
Kann man schon muss man sich aber dann auch wirklich daran halten
Ne, nachvollziehen kann das kein Mensch mehr.
Ich hab tatsächlich, ihr mögt es mir jetzt glauben oder nicht,
ich hab tatsächlich einen Kommentar drüber geschrieben.
Aber glaubt ihr mir eh nicht.
Weil, ihr wisst ja, ich praktiziere ja Error-Free-Programming, da braucht man das nicht.
Ich hab nen Kommentar drüber geschrieben
Aber es glaubt mir eh keiner, dass ich nen Kommentar drüber geschrieben hab
Ich hab drüber geschrieben
Das ist aber auch nicht so wirklich hilfreich
Sagt
Sagt, aber muss so sein
Ich weiß nicht, fändet ihr das Kommentar hilfreich?
Ich glaube, so wirklich bringen tut es keine was
Aber
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Self-Documenting-Code, genau.
Und das ist jetzt...
Also das war jetzt kein Witz, ne?
Ich hab das wirklich
ZZZ Dirty Hack genannt.
Du wirst es irgendwann selbst lesen und nicht mehr verstehen.
Ja, gehe ich auch von aus.
Man kann das bestimmt viel schöner und einfacher machen,
aber mir ist noch nichts eingefallen dazu.
So, gut.
Chat, wer auch immer das gefragt hat,
Frage beantwortet, was ich auf der Arbeit mache.
Was die KI zu meinem Problem sagt,
Die hat sich irgendwas komisches zurecht halluziniert.
Ich habe Gemini Pro 2.5 gefragt.
Weil die intern bei uns noch nicht geupdatet haben.
Und das hat sich irgendein Mist zusammen halluziniert, was keinen Sinn ergeben hat.
Dann habe ich mal bei Office 365 Copilot gefragt und das war deutlich besser.
Der hat aber irgendwas von wegen SNI und weitere Listener und so geschrieben.
Das Problem bei SNI ist, SNI funktioniert nicht richtig mit Wildcard-Zertifikaten.
2.5 ist outdated as fuck. 2.5 ist vom März 2025.
Das ist Steinzeit bei KI-Models.
Der M365 Copilot war tatsächlich besser, ja.
Jaja.
Ich benutze tatsächlich relativ viel Copilot bei mir auf der Arbeit jetzt,
weil unsere Models so outdated sind.
Die haben sich ja von Google so eine quasi geforkte, also du kannst dir sowohl bei Google als auch bei Microsoft, kannst du dir quasi einen privaten KI-Fork kaufen, wenn du es willst.
Ja, du bekommst dann quasi ein eigenes GPT, wo angeblich die Daten auch nur innerhalb von Europa gelagert werden und nicht zum Training verwendet werden und bla bla bla.
und das haben die sich gekauft
von Google, also von Microsoft.
Das Problem ist, das ist halt outdated as fuck.
Das ist GPT 5.1, was wir glaube ich
da maximal jetzt haben und Gemini
Pro 2.5. Das ist beides outdated
as fuck. Aber glücklicherweise haben wir
mittlerweile auch Copilot, Office 365
Copilot freigeschaltet
und der ist ganz brauchbar.
Keine Ahnung.
Glaube ich nicht.
MonkaS.
Ja, wir sind auch öfters am Flamen,
dass wir Entropic Models haben wollen,
aber anscheinend ist es da mit
Datenschutz und allem möglichen nicht so easy.
Für was benutzt du Copilot?
Zum Beispiel um...
Also, wofür ich es öfters benutze,
ist YAML-Files reinkopieren, wenn mal irgendwas
nicht funktioniert und sagt, ey, Leute,
wo hab ich da wieder Leerzeichen vergessen?
Da ist die KI gar nicht so schlecht drin.
Jammerfalls zu korrigieren.
Für solche Sachen benutze ich die teilweise auch ganz gerne.
Ja, wenn man dann so fragt, ey, guck mal, ich brauche eine Zertifikats-Ressource für Cert-Manager mit drei Alternative-Names drin.
Oder sind die eigentlich ganz gut?
Ich könnte es auf der Arbeit gar nicht verwenden.
weil
die haben einen Proxy dazwischen,
der bricht HTTPS auf
und der hat so eine Content-Analyse drin
und sobald du KI-Sachen aufmachst, die nicht freigegeben sind,
blockt er dich.
Und er würde garantiert auch Anthropic blocken.
Hotspot mit Handy, ja, dann kann ich ja nicht Copy-Pasten.
Ne, das mach ich nicht.
Ich benutze intern auf der Arbeit nur die freigegebenen Sachen und das ist Gemini 2.5 Pro,
GPT irgendwas oder 365 Copilot.
Aber dann ist der Proxy auch nicht datenschutzkonform. Warum? Das ist doch ein Proxy von uns.
Hat er die PS-Verbindung?
Na wahrscheinlich wird irgendwo im Vertrag drin stehen, du darfst den Arbeitsrechner nur für Arbeitsdinge verwenden.
Habt ihr bei euch auf der Arbeit auch so eine Liste, was ihr benutzen dürft?
Das geht relativ dynamisch, also das meiste geht ohne Probleme im Browser auf.
Ich habe zwei Möglichkeiten.
Ich kann entweder über meine Linux-VM ins Internet gehen.
Da sind manche Sachen erlaubt, die vom Windows nicht erlaubt sind.
und ich kann über meine Windows-Kiste ins Internet gehen
und das sind manche Sachen erlaubt, die auch von meiner Linux-Kiste nicht erlaubt sind.
Deswegen, was ich manchmal mache,
was ich aber nicht so sehr an die große Glocke hängen will, Leute,
deswegen hier dürft ihr nichts verraten, okay?
Chat, Chat, nichts sagen, alles klar?
Ihr vergesst das, nachdem ich es euch erzählt habe wieder.
Gell? Nichts sagen, Chat, alles klar?
Sonst kann ich es nicht erzählen.
Nein, ich mache kein VPN nach Hause.
Also, ich leite mir manchmal per SSH-Forwarding den Proxy von meiner Windows-Kiste auf meine Linux-VM weiter.
So kann ich auf viele Sachen zugreifen, die nur von Windows ausgehen, allerdings von der Linux-Umgebung aus.
Und ich kann von der Linux-Umgebung zugreifen auf Sachen, wo ich von Windows nicht zugreifen kann.
Das heißt, ich kann dann quasi beides benutzen.
Ich mache dann SSH-Forwarding, also Port-Forwarding auf meine Linux-VM und leite das dann auf meinen Proxy weiter von der Windows-VM.
Da kann ich dann von Linux auf Sachen zugreifen, die sonst nicht gehen.
Da kann ich zum Beispiel, für eine Sache brauche ich das auch tatsächlich,
wir bekommen regelmäßig von einem Anbieter iOS- und Android-Apps geliefert.
Und auf diese Seite kann man nur öffnen über, oh wie hieß das? Ori oder so?
Ne, oh wie hieß denn das? Das ist irgend so was ganz obskures.
Die benutzen eine Software, womit du...
Also die benutzen zur Softwareverteilung Docker-Repos, haben da aber ganz normale Software-Binarys drin und keine Docker-Images.
Das hieß doch...
Ora?
Kann das sein?
Ist das irgendwie so?
Oh, fuck.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nicht O-C-I.
Es sind...
Oras!
Das da.
Oras, das meine ich.
Die benutzen...
Das ist ganz weird, Champ.
Das ist
ein Client
für OCI Registries,
wo du allerdings dann
ganz normal Anwendungen
drüber verteilen kannst.
Frag mich bitte nicht, warum die,
das ist wirklich die abgedrehteste Variante, die ich je gesehen habe,
um Software zu verteilen.
Die haben irgendwo eine Docker-Repo
oder eine OCI-Repo,
wo sie ihre iOS und Android-Apps drüber
verteilen.
und da habe ich mir diesen GoPro-Kamer,
habe ich mir diesen Client hier runtergeladen
und ich habe aber
keinen Zugriff auf das Docker-Repo
unseres Anbieters.
Und ich habe aber Zugriff auf das
Docker-Repo unseres Anbieters über meinen Windows-Proxy.
Dann proxy ich mich immer
über SSH-Forwarding auf meinen Windows-Proxy,
downloade die iOS-Anwendung
und hänge die bei uns
ans Jira-Ticket an.
Anders geht's nicht!
Das ist voll durch die Brust ins Auge, ich weiß,
aber anders geht nicht.
Mit solchen Problemen muss ich mich da auseinandersetzen, ey.
Und die fragen mich immer,
weil ich der Einzige bin, der diese Dinger runterladen kann.
Nee, wenn die das... Die wissen das ja.
Ich lade die ja für mein Projekt da runter.
Ich werde sogar von den Verantwortlichen
für die Anwendung immer gefragt, kannst du mal wieder runterladen?
Ich habe sogar ein Ticket
schon dazu erstellt,
dass das eigentlich
nicht so gedacht ist, aber...
Ja, bis jetzt gibt es da noch keine Alternative für.
Was willst du machen, ja?
So, jetzt habe ich aber ganz schön lang geschwätzt.
Alter, Leute, drei Stunden.
What the fuck?
Was habe ich denn jetzt drei Stunden bitteschön gelabert?
Wir haben GitHub-Trends angeguckt.
Aber wir können doch nicht drei Stunden GitHub-Trends angeguckt haben.
Wenn Max weg ist, wisst ihr was?
Ich geh da nicht weg.
Da ist richtig nice. Da gefällt's mir richtig gut.
Also es sei denn, oh gut, man weiß nie, wie es in 10 Jahren ist.
Vielleicht ist es in 10 Jahren kacke und ich geh woanders hin.
Aber solange das so bleibt wie jetzt,
mein Chef ist top,
die Leute im Projekten sind top,
die Leute im Team sind top,
das, was man machen kann, es gefällt mir gut.
Ich kann auch meinen Bastel
Programmiertrieb ab und zu mal ein bisschen
ausleben mit kleineren Tools und so.
Das ist super. Vor allem,
das Schöne ist,
die freuen sich sogar
da, wenn ich irgendwelche Sachen
bastle. Wie gesagt, ich habe ja
so einen Custom Prometheus Export,
das habe ich noch 50 Mal erzählt,
programmiert für unsere Blockchain-Anwendung,
die Custom-Metriken exportieren.
Der ist immer noch im Einsatz, kommt mir immer noch
regelmäßig an, fragen, ob ich da noch was einbauen kann.
Die sind richtig happy,
dass ich quasi nicht nur administrieren kann,
nicht nur Cloud-Sachen machen kann, sondern auch programmieren kann.
Das passt wunderbar. Also ich bin da
sehr glücklich aktuell.
Ne, das glaube ich nicht, dass ich jemals bei der Datenbank
bei der Bahn arbeiten werde.
Was, wenn ich dir das Doppelte am Gehalt anbiete?
Das kommt auf den Job an
Wenn der Job suckt
Würde ich es auch fürs Doppelte vom Gehalt nicht machen
Weil ganz ehrlich
Ab einer gewissen Menge
Ist es doch
Ey, fast schon egal, ja
Also da ist mir meine Zufriedenheit wichtiger
Dürfen DB-Mitarbeiter über die Bahn öffentlich flamen?
Oh, das ist eine gute Frage.
Weiß ich nicht.
Privat bestimmt.
Wenn es da keinen Zusammenhang dazu gibt,
dass sie Bahnmitarbeiter sind.
Könnte aber auch sein, dass da irgendwas im Vertrag drin steht.
Aber was die sich privat äußern dürfen,
darf dir dein Arbeitgeber eigentlich nicht vorschreiben.
Solange du es nicht damit in Verbindung bringen kannst.
Okay, Leute.
Jetzt gucken wir aber mal ein paar Videos.
Ich habe jetzt so viel geschwätzt,
ich weiß gar nicht, was ich eineinhalb Stunden alles gelabert habe.
Die Tab-Anzahl...
Ja, Moment. Ich hab da auch noch Tabs.
Und ich hab hier auch noch Tabs.
Also, wenn schon, dann richtig.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Ich mein, nein, ah.
Kein Homesource.
Warum Offenbach boomt, Leute?
Hafti Abi
Oh, das sind die High Performer hier
So erkennen
alle KI-Inhalte
Ah, das wollte ich gucken
Die raten, ob ein Video
KI generiert ist oder nicht
Das war's für uns, da können wir mitraten
Max, du brauchst ein Overlay-Tool, das die aktuelle Anzahl an Tabs anzeigt.
Meinst du, soll ich selbst programmieren?
Dieses Video ist KI-generiert.
Klar, hätte die Aufmerksamkeit nicht gesagt hätte, aber bei dem hier ist es dann schon deutlich schwieriger, oder?
KI-Videos sind in den letzten Monaten auf jeden Fall deutlich besser geworden.
Genauso wie KI-Stimmen, weil das gerade war gar nicht meine echte Stimme, sondern mein...
Ja, das hat man aber gehört.
Generell muss man sagen, KI-Stimmen sind...
Also man kann sich, man kann sich das mittlerweile direkt geben.
Also ich kann mir durchaus Videos mittlerweile anhören, die komplett von KI gesprochen werden.
Aber man muss schon sagen, KI-Voice-Over ist immer noch ein bisschen wenig mitreißend.
Ja, das trifft es glaube ich ganz gut.
Du kannst einer KI-Stimme zwar sagen, ich will, dass das super gehypt ist, dann hört sich das aber immer gehypt an.
Oder du musst halt wirklich sehr viel prompten für die Einzelnen.
Aber man hört's, man hört's, ja.
Ein KI-Stimmklon.
Ja, alles ganz schön verwirrend.
Ist auch ein bisschen leise, oder?
Und natürlich potenziell gefährlich.
Die KI-Fakes sind ja auf Social Media jetzt schon allgegenwärtig.
Uns hat interessiert, kann man KI-Videos noch einigermaßen einfach als Fakes erkennen?
Kommt drauf an.
Also wenn die gut gemacht sind, ist es verdammt schwer.
Gerade bei Videos mit nicht viel Bewegung.
Ja, so Fake-Videos von irgendwelchen Politikern, die irgendwas sagen, das ist schwer.
Das ist wirklich schwer.
Weil die stehen dann einfach nur gerade vor der Kamera, es bewegt sich nichts dahinter.
Das ist teilweise echt schwer zu erkennen.
Oder ist das schon vorbei?
Und ich dachte, wenn das vielleicht noch einer auseinanderhalten kann,
dann ja hoffentlich meine Kollegen hier bei CT3003.
Und deswegen habe ich ein Quiz erstellt. Einige KI-Videos gemischt mit echten Kameraaufnahmen.
Und Sahin, Chris und Keno schauen die jetzt gemeinsam mit euch und versuchen die KI zu erkennen.
Wir raten mal mit.
Ihr könnt mitraten und am Ende gebe ich euch noch ein paar handfeste Tipps und Tricks, mit denen ihr in Zukunft KI-generierte Inhalte zuverlässig erkennen könnt.
Also bleibt dran.
Liebe Hackerinnen, liebe Internet-Zollfahrer, herzlich willkommen hier bei...
KI-Videos können zur richtigen Desinformationsgefahr im Internet werden.
Eine andere Gefahr...
Jetzt kommt erstmal Cell-Out.
Skippen wir mal kurz.
Okay.
Wie KI oder echt?
Also, zeig mal her.
Abo.
Erbung.
Ende.
Das läuft da so perfekt.
Runter.
Umfrage? Okay, okay, okay.
Gute Idee.
Wir machen Umfrage.
Aber erst will ich es mir mal angucken.
Okay? Erst will ich
echt oder KI.
Machen wir mal.
KI, echt.
Okay.
Geht eine Minute.
Könnt ihr mit abstimmen im Chat.
Also es ist schon sehr weich.
Okay, so hier kommen Kaffeebohnen.
Sehr flüssig alles.
Hm.
Aber.
Es wirkt alles schon so weich.
Aha.
Ich glaube, Chad, guckt euch mal die Physik hier an.
Guckt euch mal die Physik hier an.
Die sieht ziemlich echt aus, oder?
Guckt mal.
Blub.
Die Physik sieht schon ziemlich echt aus.
Ich sag, das ist echt.
Für mich ist immer so ein Indiz, dass es weich ist.
Ja, das dachte ich mir auch.
Das ist so weich und smooth und flüssig und so, ja.
Sieht halt so ein bisschen selbstgemacht aus, weil irgendwie die Kamera so ein bisschen...
Ich sag wegen der Physik, das ist echt.
Wenn es wackelig ist.
Okay, der Chat sagt, 63% sagen KI.
Ja, ich würde sagen.
Aber ohne Scheiß, es könnte auch genauso KI sein.
Aber ich sag, wegen der Physik am Ende, sag ich echt.
Ich sag, das ist KI.
Ich würde sagen, das ist KI, weil die Bewegungen der Bohnen irgendwie weird aussehen.
Die schwimmen so ein bisschen, das ist physikalisch nicht korrekt.
sieht halt auch sehr perfekt aus.
Aber dafür ist das hintere halt
wie die da so unter.
Aber das hier ist halt, das hier hinten
sieht halt schon, gerade wenn die letzten paar
Bohnen da hinten runterfallen und abprallen
und springen, nachdem ja
KI nicht versteht, was es macht,
tun die sich mit Physik dann teilweise schon schwer.
Ich sage es echt, weil wegen der
Kamerabewegung. Es ist echt?
Also es ist Physik. Es ist echt!
Krass. Das ist echt.
Verdammt!
Das ist richtig.
Yes!
Chat falsch, Max richtig.
Das ist KI.
Das sieht irgendwie voll KI aus.
Hier sehe ich übrigens jetzt schon,
an dem Gesichtsausdruck, in dem Stillframe
sehe ich das jetzt schon,
dass das nicht echt ist, weil man hier,
also ich lege mich jetzt noch nicht fest, aber ich sage,
Das sieht wie ein typisches KI-Video aus.
Ich weiß leider schon, dass ich jetzt schon Indikationen habe, dass es nicht echt ist, weil in dem Fahrradhelm auch dieses KI-Gematsche so ein bisschen drin ist.
Also...
Ja, aber wie sich die Lippe bewegt
und der Gesichtsausdruck
und
der Winkel wieder reinguckt
und das Auto bewegt sich, wenn er
dranschlägt und so,
das ist KI. Also ich finde, das hat
so einen KI-Vibe.
Wenn das nicht AI ist,
dann wäre das wirklich
weirdes Stock-Footage, sag ich mal.
Ja. Das ist KI, das zweite. Das sieht man an der Reflexion im Spiegel.
Was ich allerdings faszinierend finde, ist, dass dieser Sicherheitsdruck...
Was hat er denn auf seinem Trikot stehen? Ergibt es Sinn, was er auf dem Trikot stehen hat?
Nee, oder?
Dieses Sicherheitslogo in dem Autoglas, irgendwie diese Sekurität.
Das ergibt doch keinen Sinn, was der hier auf seinem Trikot stehen hat.
Ich glaube, dass das da so drin ist und auch die ganze Zeit an der richtigen Stelle bleibt, glaube ich.
Ich gucke nochmal.
Aber ich finde halt, dass auch diese sehr übertriebenen Gesichtsausdrücke...
Ja, genau, genau.
Das ist auch irgendwie so ein...
Also ich sage auch...
Wie gesagt, ich habe gleich gesagt, das ist KI, ich bleibe dabei.
Diese, diese...
Keine Ahnung, wo die ihr Trainer...
Ach so, wir müssen Umfrage machen, Chat.
Kann man den letzten nochmal starten?
Okay, ihr könnt aber abstimmen.
Wups, sehr laut. Oh, Chat-Gill.
Call to Action, wie sich so schön nennt.
Ihr könnt mal bei mir auf die Channel About-Page gehen.
Da gibt es einen Rev-Link zu einem Alternate-Shop, wo ihr aktuell günstig U-Creen-Nasses und Festplatten kaufen könnt.
Alternativ, wenn ihr nicht auf die Profilseite gehen wollt, Ausrufezeichen U-Creen, Ausrufezeichen Seagate im Chat.
Da gibt es das auch.
Die Preise sind wirklich günstig und gelten nur über meinen Link.
So, schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal, was der Chat, was der Chat meint.
Okay, okay.
In dem Fall sind wir uns einig.
97% KI.
Okay.
Wenn das jetzt echt ist,
habe ich voll reingeschissen.
Aber wie gesagt, ich bleibe dabei, das ist KI.
Phänixmaterial, aber das ist alles ein bisschen zu
fraxenhaft.
Grotesk.
Also hier würde ich sagen, das ist KI.
Noch richtig, das ist KI.
Siehst du?
Ich sage, es ist AI.
Wir haben recht, Chat.
Ich hatte nur Angst, dass ich alles falsch mache.
Ja, ist KI, richtig.
Auf die Reflektionen achten, wäre auf jeden Fall von mir ein Tipp.
Das hilft auf jeden Fall, um KI-Inhalte gut erkennen zu können.
So Dinger sind echt schwer.
So Dinger sind saumäßig schwer zu erkennen.
Die Beleuchtung könnte falsch sein?
Aber auch wie das bei ihm am Kopf alles vorbeifliegt, ohne da irgendwie...
Okay, Chat.
Chat, ich hab ehrlich gesagt
ich tendiere auch zu echt
aber
wir müssen, in dem Fall
müssen wir keine Umfrage machen
weil der Chat hat sich schon selbst gespoilert
und er sagt, das Video ist bekannt und echt
wir gehen jetzt einfach, wir gehen jetzt einfach mal davon aus
der Mehrheit des Chats sagt, es ist echt
das ist so ridiculous, das ist
quasi schon wieder
echt sein könnte auch.
Ich kenne die Szene nicht.
Ist halt irgendwie ein lustiger Prankster,
Schrägstrich Aktivist.
Ich sage das echt.
Also das ganze Setup von dieser Szene
sieht echt aus. Also ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
dass es eine...
Es ist Sepp Blatter ist das, ne?
Von dieser Pressekonferenz, die sah wahrscheinlich
genauso aus, dass Sepp Blatter da irgendwie saß.
Aber die anderen Typen sehen irgendwie
komisch aus. Und?
Mal ganz kurz.
Ah, ja, gut, gut, gut.
Ich meine, dass die Namensschilder hier irgendwie Sinn ergeben.
Warte mal, warte mal.
Wie der Typ da vorbeigeht.
Was war jetzt?
Hier.
Ach nee, das sind zwei.
Das sind zwei Dudes.
Das sind zwei Dudes
Ja, das passt auch
Auch, dass die hier zeitgleich sich angucken
Und so
Guck mal, die gucken sich da auch zeitgleich an
Also, ich würde schon sagen
Ja, ich würde auch sagen, das ist echt
Schöner Name
Aber so Dinger sind echt schwer.
Weil ich das Video kenne.
Da legt dieser Aktivist, er legt ihm da Falschgeld hin, um auf die Bestechlichkeit der FIFA hinzuweisen.
Das habe ich damals gesehen.
Also man sieht, dass das halt auf authentischem Material basiert.
Also das ist ja auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Das hat so diese early 2000er Fernsehästhetik.
Dieser Typ in der Mitte da, der sieht irgendwie komisch unecht aus.
Also das ist jetzt, ich finde das ist jetzt für mich am schwierigsten. Ich tendiere, ich sage jetzt mal 60% KI, 40% nicht KI, deswegen sage ich jetzt KI.
Das ist ein echtes Video.
Ah, scheiße.
Chat, ihr habt recht.
Na gut.
Das ist echt.
Yes.
Was ist das, was ist da genau passiert?
Das war zu Sepp Blatters FIFA-Zeiten. Da ist ein Aktivist auf die Bühne und hat ihn mit Geld beworfen und gesagt, ihr seid so ein gerobter Scheißhaufen.
Hat sich nicht viel geändert seitdem.
Nee.
Heute hätten sie ihn mit orangiger Farbe besprüht.
Wenn ich die Szene nicht gekannt hätte,
wär's schwieriger gewesen, weil das so bizarr ist,
dass man denken könnte, das ist auf jeden Fall AI.
Das könnte man schon leicht für AI halten, würd ich sagen.
Auch diese beiden Typen ...
Wie die fliegen, das wär für KI sehr schwierig.
Das stimmt. Die würden dann so ein bisschen morfen,
manche davon und so, das stimmt.
Okay, Chat.
Wieder Umfrage.
KI oder echt?
Boah, so Dinger sind auch immer saumäßig schwer rauszufinden, ey.
So die Wellen können wir uns vielleicht mal hier unten angucken, ob die Sinn ergeben.
Ein Drohnenflug über...
Ist das eine Straße? Das sieht alles sehr unecht aus.
Vor allem die Wellen und so. Weil das halt eher aussieht wie so eine Regenrinne.
Das stimmt. Aber der Rest sieht echt gut aus.
Das sieht sehr gut aus, aber der Inhalt ergibt halt keinen Sinn. Was soll das sein?
Ist das ein Weg, der zu einem Aquädukt wird oder so was? Oder so eine Wasserstraße?
also was soll das das stimmt schon sein so seelenloses stock footage ist halt immer
schwer das ist echt schwer ist das ende ergibt keinen sinn das stimmt aber der rest sieht echt
wirklich gut aus ich muss mir das noch mal kurz den groß angucken
Aqueduct. Aber guck mal, sogar hier
geht irgendwie... Was soll das
hier sein? Ist das hier Schatten?
Aber guck mal, hier...
Guck mal, guck mal, guck mal, guck mal. Hier sind Streben
im Schatten. Hier ein bisschen auch
und hier vorne sieht man die dann.
Das ist einfach Schatten.
Das ist einfach Schatten hier. Aber warum
hört der Schatten auf einmal hier so auf?
Vielleicht ist das anderer Boden?
Boah!
Mein Kopf sagt, es ist echt.
Mein Herz sagt, es ist KI.
Wenn man es mal so umschreiben darf.
Bauchgefühl sagt, es ist KI.
Kopf sagt, es ist echt.
Boah, scheiße.
Das ist echt schwer.
Ich muss mir nochmal die Wellen angucken.
Aber der Inhalt ergibt halt keinen Sinn.
Was soll das sein?
Ist das ein Weg, der zu einem Aquädukt wird oder sowas?
Oder so eine Wasserstraße?
Ha!
Also, was soll das?
Doch, ich sag es.
Es ist KI.
Ich sag auch, es ist KI.
Ich sag doch, es ist KI.
Es ist KI.
Oh, was kam bei der Umfrage jetzt eigentlich raus, Chat?
Äh...
KI kam raus? Okay.
Ich sag auch KI.
So seelenloses Stock-Footage ist halt immer schwer.
Die sind so... Die wobbeln so ein bisschen durch die Gegend.
Kann natürlich irgendeine Kameraeinstellung sein.
Die Wellen sehen so zeitlupenmäßig aus,
aber die Drohne sieht aus, als würde sie sich normal bewegen.
Das ist KI.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich sag, das ist KI.
Das ist KI.
Oh, haben wir aber Glück gehabt.
Okay, next.
Können wir abstimmen?
Äh, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Was ist mit den Wasserspritzern da unten?
Das sieht nicht echt aus.
Guck mal.
Naja.
Das finde ich schwer.
Das ist KI auch.
Der Hund
bewegt sich zu flüssig
und perfekt.
Ja.
Also da würde ich, ich würde auch
zu KI tendieren.
Aber guck mal, die Reflektionen
Das sieht schon nicht schlecht aus.
Aber die Reflexion ergibt doch keinen Sinn, oder?
Guck mal, die Pfütze ist doch viel zu weit weg vom Auto.
Naja, wobei.
Ja, oder?
Ja.
Wobei der Winkel war halt...
Also das sieht zu gleichmäßig aus mit dem Hund.
Und was ist hier innen mit den Ohren?
Guckt mal.
Was ist hier mit den Ohren?
Innen.
Und die Haare hier hinten?
Also für mich ist auch das Laufen, dass der Hund sieht und vom Licht her passt es irgendwie.
Es ist schwierig, aber ich sage auch KI.
Chad sagt auch KI.
Das ist für mich schwer hier, das hier.
Das ist KI auch, weil die, diese Splashes unten bei den ersten paar Schritten des Hundes.
Ah, nee, da ist aber auch die Pfütze.
Ja, genau das habe ich mir auch ganz am Anfang angeguckt.
Dass das auch immer splasht, wenn da wirklich eine Pfütze ist.
Das gibt mir sofort so doll AI.
Aber wenn es zu obvious ist,
dann habe ich immer Angst, dass ich hier verarscht werde.
Weil dieser Hund sieht auch schon wieder so weich aus.
Ja, genau.
Der ist wahrscheinlich auch weich.
Der bewegt sich auch viel zu gleichmäßig und perfekt.
Die Bewegung.
Ja, und der Hund, der sieht auch viel zu von den Dimensionen her.
Ah, ja, Leute, da müssen wir gar nicht drüber diskutieren. Zu 100 Prozent. Meine Mutti würde ich darauf verwenden, das ist zu 100 Prozent KI. Wir haben hier diese weichen Rundungen auch in den Pfützen und in dem Bordstein. Die Autos sehen so ein bisschen unecht aus. Der Hund sieht sowieso ein bisschen CGI-mäßig zu perfekt aus. Das ist einfach 100 Prozent KI.
Das ist richtig.
Och, wir haben recht, Chad.
KI.
Dann würde ich aber dann doch sagen, dass das echt ist.
Ja, das ist echt.
Nee.
Nee? Ach, scheiße.
Ich sage es AI.
Ja.
Okay, nächstes.
Okay, lass mal kurz, wir müssen von Anfang an gucken.
Was ist denn das hier für komische Zeichen daneben?
Und dieses Schild, was ist das?
Gibt es das wirklich?
China-Chinesen-Zeichen.
Ansonsten sieht das echt sehr echt aus.
So, das Straßenschild sieht schon mal ein bisschen weird aus.
Ja, das habe ich auch gedacht.
Das ist aber schwer.
Aber es könnte jetzt auch irgendein
sein, was man nicht kennt.
Die Schriftzeichen auch.
Die Schrift ist weird.
Die Schrift ist weird, genau.
Guckt euch das an.
Das habe ich mir auch gerade gedacht.
Guck mal, die haben fast das gleiche
Kennzeichen, alle beide Autos.
SSZ 780.
Ja, dann sage ich auch, das ist KI.
Chet hat auch KI.
Das Logo auch.
So Dashcam-mäßig soll das ja wahrscheinlich sein.
Und ein Auffahrunfall, das sieht halt von der Physik her, wie das Auto da rein dotzt, das sieht für mich total unecht aus.
Das ist alles zu sauber.
Aber es könnte natürlich auch eine Dashcam sein, die das Bild sehr sauber macht.
Aber guck mal, Leute, hier haben wir genau diese Star Wars Alien-Zeichen.
hier am Kennzeichen.
SSZ 7, 8.
Dann sollte es ja eigentlich eine 3 sein.
Dann sieht es zwischendurch aus wie eine 0.
Jetzt sieht es aus wie ein spiegelverkehrtes C.
100% KI.
Ja, ist KI.
Okay, wir haben recht, Chat.
Das ist KI.
Wegen den Nummernschildern.
Chat, ich bin zu faul, jedes Mal einen neuen Poll zu machen.
Wollt ihr einen neuen Poll haben bei jedem Video?
Ich bin übelst faul.
Schreibt doch einfach in Chat rein, echt oder KI.
Das ist eigentlich viel besser.
Da sieht man es so im Großen und Ganzen.
Ja, typischen
Font-Rendering-Artefakten.
Das ist AI.
Ja.
Auch bei dem Nummernschild ist ja wirklich
alles verkehrt. Der war relativ easy.
Okay, bis jetzt waren wir richtig hier.
Okay, es sieht
irgendwie unecht aus,
aber das
kann durchaus echt sein.
So, jetzt haben wir hier...
Boah, shit.
Also ich tendiere irgendwie erstmal zu echt.
Aber lass uns das nochmal angucken genauer.
Hier ein Deutschlandspiel.
Eine Massenszene.
Muss mir das hier nochmal angucken.
Genau, was ist das hier neben für eine Schrift schon mal?
Was ist das für eine Schrift?
Also anhand der Szene hätte ich es nicht erkannt,
aber die Schrift sieht halt überhaupt nicht nach...
nach irgendwas aus
jetzt haben wir hier in deutschland spiel
eine massenszene
also das sieht auch er hat doch
die mäßig ist auch gar nicht
wobei also es hat mir am anfang keine kai im weibs
gegeben
wenn ich mich schriftlos gucken
dreckig aus
Die Schrift sieht halt super nach KI aus.
Also echt.
Aber hier habe ich auch wieder dieses Thema,
dass ich bei diesem gelben...
Und die springen auch so weich zusammen hier.
Guck mal.
Wie springen wirklich so viele Leute so krass synchron?
Was ist das? Container oder so?
Da ist so Text drauf,
der nicht wie Menschensprache aussieht,
sondern da sehe ich halt so...
Das sieht halt aus wie so, keine Ahnung, Tierkreiszeichen.
Das ist immer das tricky Zeug, wenn es irgendwie so schlechte Aufnahmen sind, schlechte Quali,
irgendwelche Überwachungskameras oder so.
Die Fahne, guck mal, die Fahne hier, mit der stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
Guckt euch mal die Fahne an, wie die weht.
Guck mal.
Das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Also ich sag KI,
aber ich würd's auch am Ende nicht wundern,
wenn's echt ist.
Von da so Leute ineinander,
da verschmelzen einfach Leute miteinander.
Links oben ist auch die Schrift sehr weird,
also es sieht nicht aus wie die richtige Schrift.
Ja, also ich sag auch KI.
Die Schrift ist immer noch so ein Giveaway anscheinend.
Das ist AI.
Deswegen würde ich sagen, das ist auch KI.
Das ist richtig, das ist KI.
Das ist ein Image to Video.
Also das ist ein echtes Bild gewesen, aber er hat dann diese authentische Schrift so verfälscht, als er sich versucht hat zu bewegen.
Ja, das ist KI. Auf jeden Fall, das sieht man am Bildrand, da sind einzelne Menschen, die so morphen und so, das ist auf jeden Fall KI.
Genau, das ist das, was passiert, wenn man ein echtes Bild in die KI reinschmeißt und sagt, lass die Leute mal eine Massenpanik bekommen.
Oh, das ist...
Das könnte ich mir bei dem halt echt vorstellen.
Ah, guck mal, da hinten, was ist das für eine Schrift da hinten?
Ich möchte immer mal...
Ne, guck mal, drei...
Das sieht nach echter Schrift aus, oder?
Leck.
Drei im...
Was heißt das?
Drei in einem oder sowas?
Drei im Weg?
Im Weg oder irgendwie sowas?
Im Weckle.
Ja, okay, das ist echt.
Das ist echt.
Das ist tricky, ne?
Der Söder.
Initial habe ich gedacht, okay, das ist echt,
aber wie er dann abbeißt, sieht irgendwie weird aus.
Vielleicht beißt er auch einfach nur weird ab.
Vielleicht beißt er auch einfach so ab.
Stimmt, der beißt nicht ins ganze Kutsch,
nur in die Wurst.
Ich sage, das ist echt.
Markus Söder ist einfach immer Fiebertraum.
Das ist wirklich...
Das ist so ekelhaft.
Also drei im Weckler sind an sich völlig okay, aber ja.
Also das sieht mir nach authentischem Markus-Content aus.
Warum hat der denn drei Bratwürste in seinem Brötchen?
Aber das wird vielleicht in Nürnberg so gehandhabt.
Markus, wenn du das hier siehst, lass mich mit deinem Wurstgefresse in Ruhe.
So schlimm und widerlich das ist, das ist echt, weil das Schild hinten im Hintergrund stable ist, also der Font ist so unscharf und so, das ist auf jeden Fall immer schwierig, solche unscharfen Sachen stable zu halten.
Und auch so da dieses komische, diese Plastik-Tomaten-Deko, die da unter der Decke hängt und so weiter.
Das ist alles so unscharf, aber stable und morpht so kein bisschen ineinander.
Es wäre auch genug Trainingsmaterial vorhanden gewesen.
Also es ist jetzt keine komplett bizarre Situation.
Das ist echt.
Okay, gut.
Das ist letztes Jahr auf dem Nürnberger Christkindlesmarkt entstanden.
Ja, das ist echt.
Das ist richtig.
Aber ich muss sagen, das ist halt, also das ist ja nachts entstanden mit dem Handy offenbar.
Und dass die Handys bauen ja auch so komische Weichzeichnungsfilter ein, die dann auch immer so ein bisschen KI-mäßig wirken.
Das AI.
Das echt?
Was?
Markus Söhler auf dem Nürnberger Christkindlesmarkt.
Ja, also das Ding ist, dass er das da macht und dieses Video aufgenommen hat, völlig believable.
Aber im Hintergrund, das ist wahrscheinlich auch die scheiß Quali.
Ich dachte, dass ich da auch irgendwie Schrift erkenne, die so ein bisschen weird aussieht.
Ja, war krass, okay.
Boah.
Aber wie das hier brennt unten und so nah, wie die Leute da dran stehen, das kann doch eigentlich nur KI sein, oder?
Weil das ist...
Also das macht Dreck und das ist heiß as fuck.
Die Leute geben mir irgendwie KI-Vibes.
Was, das Bein?
Moment.
Moment!
Was ist denn mit dem Bein los?
Oh.
Oh Gott.
Da steht jetzt die Buma.
quasi Hexenverbrennung einfach mit so einem scheiß Tierroller.
Ich glaube, dass das schon mal passiert sein könnte, so eine Szene.
Aber ich glaube, es ist AI.
Auch dieses langsam drumherum Getrehe ist auch was.
Ich glaube, unten auf dem Akku ist irgendwie so auch wieder Schrift drauf,
die komplett weird aussieht, die auch so durchscheint durch das Feuer.
Und im Hintergrund sieht man auch...
Das brennt auch zu perfekt, ne?
Das brennt auch zu perfekt einfach.
Weil auch wieder, ich glaube, unten auf dem Akku ist irgendwie so auch wieder Schrift drauf, die komplett weird aussieht, die auch so durchscheint durch das Feuer.
Und im Hintergrund sieht man auch, sieht man so ein Straßenschild, so Spielstraße.
Und das sieht auch irgendwie ein bisschen anders aus.
Das sieht ziemlich echt aus.
Also ich sag's, es kann ja auch wieder das Thema mit der Schrift.
Wir haben ja auf dem Akku, da steht irgendwas, was auch irgendwie keinen Sinn ergibt, so richtig.
Die Beleuchtung stimmt auch einfach nicht.
Also das helle, orange, gelbe Licht von dem brennenden Roller.
Ja, guck mal, am Anfang hat es hier oben noch gebrannt und jetzt nicht mehr.
Überhaupt nicht in der Szene so richtig.
Also der schwebt da auch so ein bisschen.
Der ist da gar nicht richtig 100 Prozent drin.
Also diese Roller gibt es.
Der deutsche gelbe Sack ist auch sehr authentisch.
Und das Vorsichtspielen-Schild sieht auch gut aus.
Aber das brennt mir ein bisschen zu doll.
Ich finde das Handy von der Frau mit der...
Wie gesagt, dass die Leute da so nah dranstehen, ist kein Mind-Forst.
Die Jolettenjacke irgendwie komisch.
Der Scale ist auch gar nicht hundertprozentig.
Der Roller ist eigentlich ein Tick zu groß, würde ich sagen.
Oder die Kamera ist so niedrig, das ist irgendwie wirklich nicht richtig realistisch.
Das ist KI.
Die Leute im Hintergrund haben teilweise zwei Handys in der Hand und vier Finger.
Der Typ hat auch so eine komische Sonnenbrille da.
Die Sonnenbrille, also er hat die McDonalds-Sonnenbrille mit den roten Bügeln irgendwie von 1993.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein echtes Ausgangsfoto.
Ach krass, okay.
Dass ich halt so gepromptet habe, dass der Scooter brennen soll.
Also da bin ich aber nicht zu 100% sicher.
Ich sage aber trotzdem KI.
Das ist ein KI-generiertes Video, das aber auf einem echten Bild basiert.
Das heißt, der gelbe Sack hat es einfach so gelassen.
Die Frau im Hintergrund mit dem violetten Shirt hat zwei Handys.
Die filmt einmal hochkant und einmal hin.
Ja, stimmt.
Stimmt.
Ja gut, aber ich finde es auch beliebewillig, dass da so eine Nina steht,
die halt mit so einem Doppelmodus alles für die WhatsApp-Story abfilmen.
Uh!
Da wüsste ich jetzt erstmal nicht, was da für KI spricht.
Also mein Bauchgefühl sagt erstmal echt.
Aber das ist
Das, da bewegt
Boah, ey, das
Das ist schwer
Alles für die WhatsApp-Story-Abfilm
Boah, das ist schwer
Okay, der Wiener Christkindlmarkt
Ich sag
Das ist auch ein schwieriges Film
Ich sag, das ist echt
Weil das halt nicht so ein
sehr generisches
Motiv. Ja, ich sag, das ist echt.
Also mit den Viehackern, die da in Wien rumlaufen,
das ist auch alles sehr echt.
Guck mal, die Speichen und so alles.
Echt aus, es vermatscht
da nix. Ist das die Hofburg?
Keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich nicht. Mach ich mich jetzt wieder hier lächerlich.
Gutes Font-Rendering,
dieser Christkindl-Markt. Also wenn
das AI ist, dann ist das auch Image-to-Video.
Ja, ich würd sagen, das ist echt.
Das ist sehr stable.
Was stand eben auf dem Auto drauf?
Ja, ich würd sagen, das ist echt.
Nein, nein, das ist echt. Das ist echt.
Das ist sehr stable.
Warte mal. Noch nicht einloggen, noch nicht einloggen.
Da sind Sachen drin, wie zum Beispiel dieser Transporter, der da durchfährt mit diesem Main-Logo und so weiter.
Wenn das Image-to-Video wäre, dann glaube ich nicht, dass er das so aus dem Nichts, weil das in dem ersten Frame nicht sichtbar ist, würde er es nicht so gut synthetisieren.
Ah, Font-Rendering ist auch, ne, Klassiker.
Ja, dass die Fonts halt richtig aussehen, also auch nicht nur, dass die Buchstaben da sind und keine komischen kyrillischen Sonderzeichen oder so enthalten und auch, dass das Kerning einigermaßen plausibel ist, also die Abstände zwischen den Buchstaben und so und ja, insgesamt das ganze Erscheinungsbild. Doch, das ist echt.
Einloggen?
Ja.
Das ist echt.
Okay, haben wir recht.
Setout-Modus? Ah, jetzt nicht.
Ich sag's echt.
Ja, ist echt.
Also da gibt es für mich keine Indikatoren für KI, aber es könnte natürlich KI sein, aber ich sag, es ist nicht KI.
Also ist es ein echtes Video.
Das gibt mir irgendwie ein bisschen KI-Vibes.
Auch weil das so langsam ist.
Weil das so Zeitlumen-mäßig ist.
Oh Gott.
Wie sieht denn die Schrift auf dem Bier aus?
Alice?
Na gut.
Aber irgendwie gibt mir das komische Vibes, dieses Video.
Uh.
Aber ich sehe da jetzt nichts direkt KI-mäßiges.
Und Video kann ich mir bei dem auch gut vorstellen.
Aber es gibt mir irgendwie KI-Vibes.
Ich kann es nicht richtig erklären,
aber es gibt mir irgendwie KI-Vibes.
Sieht relativ gut aus.
Auch so die Flasche und die Flüssigkeit in der Flasche
relativ plausibel.
Aber irgendwie sieht der Typ nicht hundertprozentig aus wie Markus Söder, würde ich sagen.
Das soll er aber sein, ne?
Das ist also right off the bat, würde ich sagen, das ist AI.
Also ja, ich kann nicht genau beschreiben, warum, aber es ist so ein Gefühl.
Die Bewegung wirkt auch wieder ein bisschen zu smooth.
Also das ist so.
Ja, genau.
Also das Bier ist so weg.
Es gibt diese, das ist so langsam, so Zeitlupen mäßig.
größte Giveaway, finde ich. Also die Bewegung
vom Bier und dann
das Bier eben in der Flasche. Ah, Markus Söder
wieder trinkt Augustina.
Aber nee, nee, nee, Markus.
Nee, nee, nee.
Das sieht komisch aus.
Mein Gefühl sagt mir, dass das KI ist.
Ja, mehr als mein Gefühl kann ich da
aber auch nicht sagen.
Mein Gefühl sagt mir auch, dass es KI ist. Ich kann es
aber nicht wirklich beschreiben.
Aber ich kann es nicht so richtig gut
pinpointen. Also es sind keine offensichtlichen
Fehler. Ich würde sagen, das Bier
verhält sich ein bisschen komisch, nachdem er den
ersten Schluck nimmt. Pass auf, am Ende ist das jetzt echt
oder so. Aber ich sage auch, das ist KI.
Aber das ist ja manchmal beim Bier so, dass es
dann so zu... Es ist ein bisschen
leer gleich beim ersten Schluck,
habe ich das Gefühl, wenn er die Flasche kippt. Aber
I don't know. Ich sage mal, tendenziell ist
das AI.
Auch wie er die Augen auf uns zumacht,
wie er so die Augen mit den Augen klimpert.
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Das ist KI.
Das ist KI.
Boah, Glück gehabt.
Image to Video, also ein echtes Markus Söder-Bild, ein echtes Augustiner-Bild.
Ah, die hast du zusammen, du hast dann gesagt...
Ja, ich hätte dem KI-Modell beides gegeben und dann gesagt, er soll das machen.
Funktioniert tatsächlich, also es gibt da bei Kling AI kein...
Aber überlegt euch mal, das ist jetzt schon teilweise echt schwierig zu erkennen.
Überlegt euch mal, wenn da einer wirklich viel Zeit und Energie in so einen Fake steckt
und das vielleicht in ein paar Jahren macht, das kriegst du dann immer auseinandergehalten.
Genau, wir versuchen das jetzt aktiv zu erkennen.
Wenn da irgendwie in irgendeiner Boomer-Facebook-Gruppe
irgendein Flat-Earth-Video oder was auch immer gepostet wird,
dahinter fragt das wahrscheinlich keiner so.
Eine Inhaltssperre, die das irgendwie unterbindet.
Man kann die sogar koksen lassen.
Das hat aber nicht so original authentisch ausgesehen.
Da gibt es wahrscheinlich zu wenig Material für.
Schade, das hätte ich gern gesehen.
Können wir das in die Outtakes packen?
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk
Das ist wieder so ein ... so ein ... so ein ...
langsames Fly-Ball-Ding.
Lass mal nach dem Schatten gucken.
Der Schatten sieht schon nochmal relativ echt überall aus.
Und passend.
Die Sachen hier unten sehen irgendwie merkwürdig aus.
Die Wohnsiedlung sieht ein bisschen zu...
zu glatt und perfekt aus wieder.
Moment, Moment.
Hat sich da gerade ein Mensch verdoppelt?
Ach, nee.
Das ist...
Okay.
Nee, hat sich nicht.
Oh, das ist schwierig.
Also der Pfeil da unten sieht schon ein bisschen merkwürdig aus.
Auch das Auto irgendwie, das ist so...
Auch viel los auf der Straße.
Das sieht mir auch ein bisschen zu...
zu Werbefilm-mäßig aus.
Es gibt mir ein bisschen
KI-Vibes, aber es kann auch einfach so aufgenommen sein.
das irgendwie gibt mir das KI-Vibes
guckt euch mal das Zeug hier an
aber gut, immerhin ist hier ein Fahrrad drauf
guckt euch mal diese komischen Pfeile da an
das macht ja überhaupt keinen Sinn
sehr clean auch
was macht dieses Schild da?
guck mal, dieses Schild da macht auch keinen
dieses Schild da macht ja an der Stelle auch überhaupt keinen Sinn
Also ich sage, es ist KI.
Das ist aber schwer.
Warum steht da ein Tor auf der Straße,
aber keiner spielt?
Außer der Typ da unten alleine.
Und es ist ganz schön viel los auf der Straße.
Guckt mal.
Vor jedem Haus spielen die irgendwas.
Das Haus vorne links.
Also ich sage, das ist KI.
Aber es ist wirklich schwierig.
Das Haus vorne links hat viel zu große Fenster als die rechts.
Oh.
Also ich sage, es ist KI.
Ich finde es aber schwierig.
Also die Pfeile auf den Straßen.
So.
Das, was mich da am meisten verwirrt.
Hier ist ein Überflug über eine amerikanische Wohnsiedlung.
Das ruckelt.
Wäre für mich ein Indikator dafür, dass es echt ist.
Ich gucke noch mal kurz auf.
Die Markierungen auf der Straße sehen für mich komisch aus.
Diese Pfeile da.
Aber das kann einfach abgebröckelt sein.
Da ist jetzt irgendwie so ein Schild.
Oh Gott, ist das schrecklich.
Diese Architektur und dann auch noch diese Häufung.
Das ist fürchterlich.
Das ist leider, leider ist das, glaube ich, echt.
Diese Hinterhöfe, absolute Höchststrafe und diese Giebel, diese komischen Doppelgiebel.
Ich kenne mich ja in so amerikanischen Suburbs nicht gut aus, aber diese Gärten da hinten,
die sehen ja total komisch aus. Ist das so? Aber wahrscheinlich ist das normal, ne? So ein Laufstall,
also ein Laufstallgarten. Aber wir haben so lange kein echtes Video mehr gehabt, ich sage es echt.
Das ist absolut grauenhaft, also wirklich diese Architektur und diese Art, wie die da in Nordamerika
Sachen bauen. Ich fand auch, dass das eine Kind da von diesen vier Kindern, die da so spielen,
Das eine Kind, war ich mir kurz nicht sicher, ob das so ein bisschen, entweder sich sehr schnell bewegt oder da so kurz ein bisschen morft.
Nee, aber es sieht trotzdem gut aus.
Aber tatsächlich habe ich mir dann diese absurden Doppelgiebel angeguckt und gesehen, dass sie überall konsistent bei jedem Haus sind.
Und dann habe ich so gedacht, okay, nee, das sieht halt aus wie AI, weil das für uns als Europäer nicht so...
Genau, wahrscheinlich sieht es für uns wie AI aus und sind es echt, aber...
...greifend ist, wie jemand so wohnen möchte.
Habe ich gesagt, ich bleibe dabei als KI.
Absolut insane, aber so konsistent in dem ganzen Ding drin, dass ich sagen würde, das ist echt.
Das ist echt.
Okay, verkackt.
Fürchterlich.
Die Zeichen auf dem Boden auf der Straße sehen irgendwie ein bisschen komisch aus.
Ich würde direkt sagen, es ist AI.
Das ist echt.
Verdammt.
Tja, haben wir falsch gelegen.
Also von der Situation her würde ich sagen, ist das KI.
Aber, weil er verschwindet auch sofort im Wasser.
Das ist doch an der Stelle gar nicht so tief, oder?
Aber, ey, boah, Alter.
Wisst ihr, wir sind jetzt schon in Zeiten,
wo Leute echte Videos machen, die wie KI aussehen sollen.
Wirkt schon mal direkt irgendwie nicht echt.
Ich weiß nicht warum.
Irgendwie ist das für mich nicht, wie eine Person fallen würde.
Er ist halt auch direkt weg.
Genau, er ist direkt weg. Das wundert mich auch.
Es sieht so aus, als wäre da das Wasser 20 Meter tief.
Es ist schwer zu sagen.
Erstmal, weil das Video so ein bisschen lo-fi ist.
und auch weil, also man sieht nicht die Splashes direkt, wie er reingeht.
Wenn man die Füße sehen würde, dann wäre es ein bisschen einfacher.
Also das Wasser sieht super echt aus, auch dass das Wasser so dreckig braun ist und so.
Also dieses, sieht alles super aus, aber wieso geht er da so komisch, warum macht er das?
Ja, also die Situation ist halt sehr KI-mäßig und dass der einfach weg ist, wundert mich auch.
Er hält ja seinen Arm so hoch.
Also und ich finde halt, dass dieser Pullover so komisch falten wirft, so weich.
Aber das Wasser sonst sieht relativ echt aus.
Also ich sage auch KI, aber das ist auch wieder so ein Ding.
Wenn es ein Video ist, was eben so eine typische KI ist, ist es echt schwierig.
Die Falten von dem Hoodie sehen irgendwie nicht so richtig echt aus, aber...
Das finde ich schwer, weil auch das Framing sich so verändert.
da so ein Zoom drin ist.
Irgendwas ickt mich daran, ich würd sagen, das ist AI.
Das ist AI.
Aber war das mehr ein Bauchgefühl als ...
Ja, war bei mir auch mehr ein Bauchgefühl.
Vor allem, weil er so instant verschwindet.
Dass so out of focus ist, das ganze Ding,
find ich's ein bisschen schwieriger zu sagen.
Also, es weist so typische Artefakte auf
und es ist ein bisschen zu viel Kontrast in diesen ...
in diesen Wellen von seinem Hoodie am Rücken.
Die Jacke sieht auch ein bisschen strange aus.
Die Falten.
Ich sag, es ist AI.
Ja, es ist AI.
Aber das Wasser sieht...
Also das ist irgendwie was, wo ich so denken würde, das kann KI nicht gut.
Diese Wasserbewegung und wenn er da reinfällt, das sieht so verdammt echt aus.
Deswegen sage ich, dass das echt ist.
Das KI generiert.
Oh, okay.
Und zwar komplett, also nur gepromptet, ohne irgendwelches Material noch.
Oh, diese, diese, okay, das sieht irgendwie von den Felsen, sieht das mega unecht aus.
Das gibt mir krasse Vibes von KI irgendwie jetzt schon, wenn ich das sehe.
Aber das kann halt auch genauso gut echt sein.
Aber das hier gibt mir irgendwie KI-Vibes.
Das sieht irgendwie unecht aus einfach nur.
Guck mal, hier unten hast du auch so zwei Straßen.
die irgendwie so nach
gar nichts
Die Straßen sehen auch merkwürdig aus.
Chat, Sekunde, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Vielen Dank.
So.
Ach, hier sind angenehme 26 Grad gerade.
Also irgendwie gibt mir das KI-Vibes.
Oh, diese Straßen.
Ich meine, das kann schon so sein, dass man...
Aber was ist das hier?
Was ist das hier für eine Straße?
Hier geht dann überhaupt nichts weiter, oder wie?
Hier ist einfach fertig?
Was ist das für eine Straße?
Hä?
Und hier unten auch.
Ey, wie geht mir das ganz starke KI-Vibes, das Bild?
Das sieht einfach aus wie von Apple diese animierten Bildschirmschoner.
Das sieht einfach so perfekt aus.
Also das ist ja nicht in meinem Alltag, dass ich irgendwie einen Indikator dafür habe, wie das aussieht,
wenn man mit einem Hubschrauber oder einer Drohne über so eine Bergkette fliegt.
Ich versuche halt immer zu gucken, ob da irgendwie so die Details wieder so rumwabbeln.
Und ich glaube, sie wabbeln so ein bisschen rum.
Also die Steine an dem Berg.
Das kann aber auch die Kamera sein irgendwie.
Ach, guck mal, da unten sieht man Autos und so.
Da bin ich mir richtig unsicher.
Nee, nee, hä?
Die Straße ist komplett...
Nee, das sind keine Autos.
Was soll das sein?
Nee.
Ich bleib bei KI.
Die Straße ist komplett weird.
Da kommt ja hier eine Straße an und...
Das habe ich auch gesagt, die Straße ist super weird.
Endet dann in so einem Kreis, so einem Halbkreis und die Autos verschwinden dann auch so komisch in der Straße und so.
Ist AI.
Ja, ist AI.
Gut.
Aha.
Ja, okay, das ist eindeutig AI.
Das sieht man unten da an den Autos, die da sich rummorfen.
Sieht natürlich unecht aus, weil es so perfekt aussieht.
Aber vielleicht ist das der Trick.
Da muss ich aber auch zugeben, dass ich das wirklich schlecht beurteilen hätte.
Ich würde sagen, das ist echt.
Das kann ich gerne.
Ah, okay.
Ja gut, ich habe ja vorhin bei dem...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe Ihnen auch schon gesagt, an die Szene erinnere ich mich,
aber man hätte natürlich auch das Freeze-Frame nehmen können.
und daraus ein neues generieren.
Auch die Art, wie Elon da agiert,
würde man eigentlich denken, so ist es echt auf jeden Fall.
Das ist echt, ja. Das ist richtig.
Ja, ich finde, ich krieg da auch so keine künstlich ...
ist künstlich-Vibes so.
Ja, aber auch, das ist fast wie dieses John Travolta-NPC-Meme.
Das ist ja so.
Trump steigt aus, aus einem ...
mit Elon.
Ja, aber diese Szenen ...
Ja gut, man kann natürlich einfach irgendwas nachprompten, was es schon gab, aber das gab es doch. Da hat er doch mit Elon vom Weißen Haus so eine Auto-Tesla-Werbeshow gemacht. So sehen Teslas aus? Ja, aber das hat ja stattgefunden und auch dieses, dass er auch nicht so richtig weiß, wie man diese, ich glaube, der hat wahrscheinlich Trump in seinem Leben noch nie eine Autotür zugemacht.
Genau, dass er so an dem Glas anfasst statt am Metall.
Und wie er sich da so rausschält, so unschön.
Das sieht schon echter aus.
Und Elon in seiner Verwirrtheit.
Ja, das ist echt.
Oh.
Das ist natürlich nicht so einfach.
Ich meine, diese Szene schon mal genau so gesehen zu haben.
Ich gucke mal auf Elons T-Shirt, was da noch steht.
Ist das ein Cyberpunk-T-Shirt?
Ich glaube, da steht Cyberpunk.
Ich sage es echt.
Das ist ein Cyberpunk-T-Shirt.
Es fällt genau unter diese Kategorie, was ich vorhin meinte.
So Situationen, die so absurd wirken.
Erstmal vom ganzen Bildaufbau und allem.
Also man sieht ja auch da gar nicht, wenn man sich jetzt nicht super krass auskennt,
dann würde man jetzt auch gar nicht unbedingt erkennen, dass das das weiße Haus ist im Hintergrund.
Aber ich erinnere mich an die Szene, weil das ja um die Welt gegangen ist.
Man könnte auch easy denken, dass das AI ist.
Aber dann halt auch sehr gut.
Alles korrekt hier der Schattenwurf von Elon, wie er vor dem Auto lang geht, die Reflektionen und so.
Das waren sie also, unsere 15 Clips.
Bevor wir gleich auflösen, wer am besten geraten hat, zeige ich euch jetzt konkret, woran man KI-Videos im Jahr 2026 noch erkennt.
Denn ja, das geht noch und auch wenn die Modelle besser werden, ein paar Tipps helfen euch sicher auch dann noch.
Fangen wir mit dem dicksten Brocken an.
Physik.
Ja, das war bei den Kaffeebohnen ja auch.
Eevee Kling oder Google Vio kennt keine Schwerkraft, kein Gewicht, die berechnet nur, welches Pixel als nächstes am wahrscheinlichsten kommt.
Bestes Beispiel war unser Angler, der ins Wasser fällt.
Der fällt nicht, der wird gefallen, wie an unsichtbaren Drähten.
Das echte Körpergewicht fehlt.
Dafür ist das Wasser in dem Clip schon sehr gut.
Das ist mir generell aufgefallen, dass die neue Generation von KI-Videogeneratoren echt gut mit Wasser klarkommt.
Auch hier dieser Wasserfall, das hätte früher viel schlechter ausgesehen.
Anders ist das bei Feuer.
Beim brennenden E-Scooter fällt auf, KI-Feuer brennt nicht, es fließt.
Eher wie so leuchtendes Plasma.
Und echtes Feuer wirft harte, flackernde Schatten auf die Umgebung.
Bei der KI fehlt der fast immer.
Weil sie anders als aktuelle Spiele nicht das Verhalten von Licht simuliert.
Stichwort Raytracing.
Witzigerweise hat uns dieselbe Physik bei einem echten Clip aufs Glatteis geführt.
Das Video, wo Sepp Blatter mit Geldscheinen beworfen wird, das sah so absurd aus, dass man vielleicht erst KI dachte.
Aber wie da jeder Schein einzeln rotiert und das Licht einfängt, das kriegt eine KI aktuell so nicht hin.
Manchmal ist also perfekte Physik der Beweis, dass es echt ist.
Genauso wie Objektinteraktion oft ein guter Indikator ist, also das Clipping-Problem.
Sobald sich zwei feste Materialien berühren, verliert die KI oft die Grenze dazwischen.
dazwischen. Wir hatten den echten Söder,
der in eine Bratwurst beißt und
dann den KI-Söder, der aus der Bierflasche
trinkt. Und achtet mal hier auf
das Zusammenspiel zwischen Flasche
und Lippen. Und im Vergleich dazu
meine Lippen und die Flasche in
einem echten Video. Das ist mittlerweile
kein großer Unterschied mehr.
Noch deutlicher ist das aber hier beim Fahrradfahrer,
der gegen das Fenster hämmert.
Eigentlich müsste sich die Hautblatt drücken.
Tut sie nicht. Die Finger
Finger bleiben rund und rutschen ohne Widerstand ab.
Denn Anatomie und Bewegung sind oft noch schwer.
Klar, auch in KI-Videos haben Menschen mittlerweile zuverlässig fünf Finger an der Hand und
einzelne Gesichter können die Modelle inzwischen fast perfekt.
Aber es bricht zusammen, sobald Bewegung oder Tiefe ins Spiel kommt.
Schaut in Menschenmengen in den Hintergrund.
Bei unserem Fernmeilen-Video sehen die Leute vorne okay aus, aber hinten verschmelzen sie
zu einem regelrechten Fleischberg.
Arme aus dem falschen Körper, Gesichter nur noch hautfarbene Flecken und besonders bei
schneller Bewegung passieren aktuell noch Fehler.
Der rennende Golden Retriever aus diesem Clip hier, das ist klassisches Ghosting, also Pfoten,
die leicht über dem Asphalt schweben und unnatürlich wirkende Bewegungen, weil die
KI den Motion Blur falsch interpoliert.
Genereller Tipp, achtet auf die Füße beim Gehen, oft rutschen die Sohlen über den Boden,
würde die Person schlittern. Und achtet auf Schrift in den Videos. Unser Gehirn ist mega
gut darin, Buchstaben zu erkennen und genau da scheitert die KI, sobald sich was bewegt.
Bestes Beispiel war unser Dashcam-Video. Solange das Nummernschild stillsteht, geht es noch,
aber sobald Bewegung dazu kommt, morfen die Zeichen in unleserliche Alien-Hieroglyphen.
Temporal Flickering nennt man das. Dasselbe passiert mit Maschendrahtsäunen oder Karomustern.
Und achtet auf unlogische Asymmetrie. Brillenbügel, die im Nichts enden oder eine Jacke, die links Knöpfe hat und rechts einen Reißverschluss.
Fünfter Punkt, die Optik. Und der hat uns echt ausgetrickst. Schaut, ob feine Texturen im Hintergrund anfangen zu wabbern.
Das nennt man Boiling, weil es aussieht, als würde das Bild leicht kochen.
Wir hatten den Drohnenflug über die Klippen von Madeira und ich war Anfang Juni erst da.
In echt flimmert das Grünzeug an der Steilwand nicht so komisch.
Die KI musste jedes Blatt aber einzeln in jedem Frame neu erfinden, weil sie keine feste 3D-Karte der Umgebung im Kopf hat.
Zum Vergleich der echte Drohnenflug über die Reihenhaussiedlung in Kanada, da bleiben Dächer, Linien und Zäune absolut starr.
Und jetzt der wichtigste Teil, der euch auch dann noch rettet, wenn die Pixel irgendwann mal perfekt sind.
Gesunder Menschenverstand.
Der wichtigste Test bei so viralen Clips, warum wird hier eigentlich gefilmt?
Warum sollte jemand mit ruhiger Hand eine leere Landstraße filmen, auf der drei Sekunden später ein Meteorit einschlägt?
Wenn die Kamera schon vorher zu perfekt drauf hält, fehlt die menschliche Reaktionszeit.
Und dann natürlich auf Logik achten.
Also beim E-Scooter explodiert ein Feuerball und die Fußgänger spazieren seelenruhig weiter.
Ja, die KI versteht Kausalität nicht.
Wenn ihr in dem Video was wirklich krasses seht, dann macht einfach den Doppelcheck.
Also sucht nach anderen Persönlichkeiten.
Vor allem, warum fängt es hier oben an zu brennen?
Ich finde es da unten.
Macht ja eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Leute, gucken wir mal kurz weiter noch.
Muss dann was futtern.
Perspektiven, andere Aufnahmen davon.
Macht einen Screenshot und schmeißt den in die Google-Bildersuche.
Weil wenn das wirklich so passiert ist, dann gibt es davon immer mehr als dieses eine Video, das ihr gerade gesehen habt.
Was gibt's? Es gibt, ich guck gerade, Hackfleischbällchen.
Und es ist diesmal echtes Hackfleisch.
Kein veganes Hackfleisch. Das gab's letzte Woche.
Reis mit Hackfleischbällchen und Tomatensauce.
Und achtet auch auf das Audio.
Viele KI-Videos werden ohne Ton erzeugt oder haben eben noch recht offensichtlichen KI-Ton.
So, das ist eure Checkliste. Physik, Clipping, Anatomie, Schrift und gesunder Menschenverstand.
Hast du einen Essensplan, hier bin ich zu faul für.
Es wäre gut, es würde richtig Performance-Boost nochmal bringen.
Aber, meine Garmin, der Trainingsplan bei der Garmin kann ja so den Fitnesszustand anzeigen.
Was der immer schreibt ist, jedes Mal BMI reduzieren, BMI reduzieren, BMI reduzieren.
Obwohl ich schon richtig viel abgenommen habe, bin ich immer noch zu dick.
Und jetzt, wo ihr das alles wisst, hättet ihr unsere 15 Clips bestimmt alle richtig erraten, oder?
Tja, unsere drei Ratenden hier hatten ja nicht bei jedem Video recht.
Chris hatte zwei Fehler und Klein und Keno hatten drei Fehler.
Das war Chris' Gewohnheit.
Alright!
Nehme ich nicht an.
Danke, danke.
Ich nehm's an.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Ja.
Wahnsinn.
Danke.
Bin nur froh, dass...
Chat, ich glaube, wir hatten nur eine Sache falsch, oder?
Das da hatten wir falsch.
Das da.
Das hatte ich falsch.
Ich habe dieses Jahr ein bisschen zugenommen, aber es hält sich in Grenzen.
Ich habe ja auch das letzte Jahr kaum
Spott gemacht.
Jetzt ist es wieder besser.
Nee, nee.
Ich bin immer noch
leichter als
vor zwei Jahren.
Vor zwei Jahren
hatte ich irgendwie 90.
Jetzt habe ich 85 oder sowas.
Zwischenzeitlich hatte ich ja schon mal
zwischenzeitlich hatte ich ja schon mal
ganz, ganz knapp
unter 80.
Sogar gar nicht so
ein halbes Jahr oder so
war das so um 80,
81.
Das war aber halt auch die Zeit, wo mir es richtig schlecht
ging.
Da habe ich dann nochmal weiter abgenommen.
Davor, also ich halt
bis 82 habe ich so eigentlich ganz gut
geschafft.
Das hatte ich auch eine Weile und dann ging es mir schlecht
und dann ist es unter 80 gefallen.
Und danach habe ich wieder ein bisschen
zugenommen jetzt.
11. Oktober 2024
282, die Assiste.
Das heißt, da habe ich
seitdem, habe ich
wieder ein bisschen zugenommen.
So 5, 6 Kilo
in
eineinhalb Jahren.
Also ich habe das nicht wirklich gehalten.
Ich habe, wie geht es schon,
eher so 85, 86.
Aber ich hoffe, dass es jetzt wieder
runter geht, jetzt wo ich regelmäßig wieder am Rennen
bin, seit ein paar Monaten.
Ich hatte 108,5
Ja, 109
So was
Chat
Schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid
Wenn ihr euch jetzt noch
günstigen Storage angucken wollt und günstige
Nasses, könnt ihr Ausrufezeichen
Ukraine, Ausrufezeichen Seagate im Chat machen oder
in meinem Twitter-Profil, äh nicht Twitter
Twitch auf der Profilseite gucken
Und
dann würde ich sagen
wir sehen uns
bis dann
Cio